[Music]
good
behind are a good
time wait a
minute like to propose a
toast to my
family someday soon
you're going to have families of your
own and if you're
lucky you remember the little
moments like
this that will
good
cheers this a Austin Carter and a good
time you're listening to the good times
right now
[Music]
[Applause]
all my life I never stopped worry about
a thing open up and shout it out never
try to sing wondering if I've done it
wrong will this Depression last for
long where have all the good times gone
hey buddies this is good times with
Steve Simone I'm hanging out with my pal
Lee say at Lee so excited we finally
have Bert the machine crer on this week
I I I'm just so I haven't heard it yet
I'm I'm just excited because both of you
are just so like it's as soon as you
walk into a room you just seem happy or
smiling dude he's the best he let me
come on his podcast two years ago to
promote my first CD and then now that
the new CD is out guys anybody by the
way anybody that bought what's up nerds
thank you very much if you enjoyed it
please leave a nice review on iTunes
same goes for the
podcast um and then I do have the
physical copies of the CDs that look
like pizza so if you want one of those
just shoot me a message but Bert was
nice enough when I did remember this to
come on his podcast and I'm like this
dude's awesome like I remember um reny
hanging out with Bert this has to be
like six seven eight years ago and he's
like dude do you know Bert ker and I'm
like I know who he is the machine and he
was like you guys would really get along
he was like you and whenever I hang out
with him it's just a blessing he's just
so so cool and you know what's crazy I
never heard the machine I never heard
him tell the machine story
really never I heard everybody tell me
about it right yeah but I never heard
him say it that's weird because it seems
like you guys and I'm sure you guys are
friends now but it seems like really
like in high school or middle school you
guys would have been we would have been
best friends yeah for sure just just
like just really like being Class Clown
like were you a Class Clown like yeah
yeah I was and I went through my idiot
phase well yeah everyone all boys do I
think you have to go through idiot phase
but that's I can't wait to do record it
in the man cave yep it was awesome and
it just starts off like we're it's just
cuz he starts talking about podcasting
and this and that and it's just the
conversation just goes and it's so
interesting it gets so cool and real but
then I was like you know and I don't
know how it weaved in but then he was
like oh yeah I totally remember my first
beer and he talks about the first time
he had beer and he talks about his TV
show and his wife and kids and things
get really serious at one point man I
just love this guy I want to hang out
with with him every day I even this how
much I love
Bert I was like cuz you know we kind of
all live near each other me you Joey
Bert all of us I was like dude if you
ever need a ride to The Comedy Store
just let me know I'll be your sober
driver that wouldn't that be the best
that's almost like Comedians in Cars
Getting Coffee but it's like your
friends and just having like a like a
Capri Sun that's what I would imagine
like a Capri Sun hilarious a Sunny
Delight on the way to The Comedy Store
it's funny because like one of the
things I say uh with Bert I was like
yeah I got to stop giving away free
ideas on the podcast for ideas for shows
and stuff I want to do and I almost did
it right now with you so this what I
want to do guys uh everybody that's been
to awesom steve.com and using the Amazon
link thank you very much everybody
that's been to it Domingos Italian deli
and enino thank you very much Don Carlos
and La Hoya thank you very much I'm
going to get out of the way I know we're
going to have a lot of new listeners CU
of the machines here so let's just sit
back have some laughs and talk about the
good times with Mr Bert
crer
[Music]
easy so this brand new batteries cuz you
know how oh I get I get panic about
whether or not uh I'm going to run out
of batteries right like it it it almost
makes the podcast unenjoyable
right cuz you have something on your
subconscious going whole [__] time
it's one of the things that I like I
always say this I I guess I don't mean
it cuz I never follow through or I mean
it but I just it it needs to be so
organic like I get emails from people
but I always say I wish I had someone to
help me I think it would change the the
scope of the podcast if there was a guy
sitting at my desk running the board
yeah I think it would um and so that's
why I I don't do it and I'm a little bit
of a micromanager you know what I do
what I do this and then I bring the card
to Lee you know the guy that produces
Joey's podcast
and then Lee does all the grownup stuff
for me the grownup stuff is so easy
though yeah it really is you know what
it was in the first few days the first
like year it took
me like a solid hour and a half to post
podcast it took me and now it takes me
like 10 minutes really to to pull the
card plug it in do it run it through
levelator is the longest thing it takes
run it through levelator throw it in a
garage band um read an intro and then
plug it in at the and then just post it
libson it really I can really fly
through it now um and so I'm glad I
learned it because I think adversely
learning that taught me how to edit
videos ah and then editing videos now
it's like even uh like some of my best
friends who have a great digital
presence just don't know how to edit a
video yeah I don't know how to do that
during the whole Tomas fat bird is fat
War I would shoot videos in the morning
that would inspire me and then I edited
them and I'd put them I'd make sure they
were a minute long and put them on um
Instagram and it increas increased my
Instagram following by I think about
50,000 people oh my and goodness and now
when I put a video on that gets 70,000
75,000 views as opposed to in the day it
was getting 10,000 views and that was
like where it was maxing out at that's
incredible it really is incredible I
gotta be honest with you I I'm not
certain I'm not certain but I I think I
The Bert is fat thing might have been
the best thing that ever happened to my
career wow isn't that crazy I've
television seven years and the most
interest anyone's ever had I must have
done something else at that time oh well
I had an hour special come out yeah and
then the and then the Machine video went
viral all at the same time our special
machine video goes viral thas fat bird
is fat happens on Rogan the week like
literally while the video still going
going viral and it was like uh it was
like the best week of my career like it
it like meaning it it gave me a bunch of
momentum for all of January which you
know were a couple important dates but
like one was the Wilbur oh in Boston
yeah and like you want to it's so shitty
I mean I say this hoping my agents and
managers never Liv listen to this but
like they called me and they were like I
think after my hour special they're like
we need to get you into the Wilbur we'll
do it in January all the build the
momentum off of the thing and we were
tring to
do 700 ticket sales which is which which
and I think any comic will tell
you doing the Wilbur is a stamp on
whether or not you can do theaters in
this country okay that's a great way to
look at it yeah so that's what they
that's what they tell you yeah if you
sell out the Wilbur that means you can
sell out theaters anywh cuz well yeah
cuz Wilbur's like 1,200 people that
means you can sell out a 600 seater in
Milwaukee yes or you can sell out a you
know a 600 seater in Vancouver and and
so and they were like I was like I don't
know I'm not ready for it I'm not ready
for it and they're like they're like no
you are and I was like no I like one of
the weird things about agents and
managers is like they don't they don't
really have like
a like I can I can tell you A lot of
people drink Fireball yeah I'm can tell
you that because I I spend the time in
the trenches and the bars yes like I
know what shots I'll tell you the shots
people buy they buy uh Jameson Y and
they buy Fireball those are the ones
people buy isn't it funny how come in
and out of Vogue they come in and out of
fashion I remember tequila was like a
[__] the majority of my career was
tequila shots yeah then Fireball showed
up and everyone was drinking Fireball
now my managers I'm sure would be like
yeah I've heard of Fireball you know but
they're not Drinkers and then they're
not in the club so they don't know that
like if Fireball said Hey Bert we want
to do a tour with you they'd be like
I've never heard of you you're not Jack
Daniels or right dice dice used to call
that street level he's like you got to
be on street level to know what's going
on when it comes to my ticket sales yeah
like I am definite street level now
there is a part that is hidden from the
comic like no one's calling me and
telling me my numberers in Buffalo in
two weeks no one's sharing that Mark
won't share it CU Mark doesn't want to
know doesn't want to let me know if I'm
tracking well that uh that maybe we
should change the deal around if it's
sold out already it's going to be like
you know maybe we can add a show and
then that's where your benefit comes
from and your agents and managers don't
want you to know cuz they want to keep
you in the dark a little bit too so that
they have some power they have some and
I say that [__] I don't mean it like
that I could easily call my agents and
my manager goes what are my numbers for
Buffalo but there is like a weird thing
so I don't know where this was going
anyway you getting built up to the
Wilbur and the bird is fat stuff and so
they're like they're like listen
wilber's not going to sell out this is
December and I go we still have a
[__] month and they're like I know
but tracking they they can tell you
where they're going to sell okay and
they're like they're they're saying
they're going to sell 700 and I was like
okay in my head I was like 700's a good
number and they're like well it's still
400 shy of what sold out is 500 shy of
what sold out is so it's only a half
full room and I was like I was and then
I you know and then you have friends
that played there and you're like hey
what did my friends do do my friends
sell it out yeah and everyone's real
sketchy about that they don't want to
tell you what other people is silly I'm
like dude I can call them yeah and go
how did you sell right cuz I I'm to and
and then tell them I'm going to sell 700
yes how did you sell I want like podcast
numbers it's like yeah it's like dude
dude what there's such the one crazy
thing that's happening right now is this
transparency between comics and what our
careers are and and and like you know I
very candidly I open my [__] deal
memos and I share it with my friends
yeah I go the this is the money I'm
making is this bad and my sometimes
they'll be like it's better than my
money and then they go what are your
numbers and we share very candidly
because you don't want to ever look like
an [__] you don't want to look like
you're greedy you don't want to look
like you're like Ari a long time ago was
like called me up and he goes hey man
you need to get more money money in
Canada and I said I was by that time I
was only doing uh the Edmonton Edmonton
uh yeah that was all I was doing I love
Dino up there and he was like I'm doing
Calgary and they're saying that your
numbers are that you're you're charging
less so they won't pay me more and I
went I don't do Calgary he goes what I
said I don't do Calgary he goes well
then whatever you're doing in Hamilton I
go I don't do Hamilton I don't do
Winnipeg I don't do anything I only do
Edmonton and he was like that's a
cuz everyone's using you as the example
saying that you're asking for three
grand and that's it and I went that's
not what I get paid he was like wait
what do you get paid so I tell him and
he goes okay all right I go listen I
know what I I know I sell I'm imagining
you and I sell exactly the same on the
road I'm almost certain of it you should
be getting at least that but now you
know that's what I got so good luck he's
the best's the patron saying of standup
Comics he's got a lot of [__] online
right now why cuz of that Jo B is fat
thas fat and he weled on the bed I
didn't know he did that I've been off
the grid for a week now well he he's
gone he's getting a lot of [__] and he's
gone I I think he's traveling he's in
the wind he's like in he's probably in a
jail cell in Southeast Asia somewhere
and he uh and
he I really hope he gets arrested for
like a hash possession in Thailand Jesus
and and we have like something to focus
on for six months where it's Frei Ari
and we start going over there well we
could just do that we could just create
that and wouldn't even know oh man I
would love that I would love that would
make so happy but anyway anyway so fre
so uh and then all that [__] happens and
then the Wilbur just sells out like all
the all the tickets sell and I was like
congrat first off congratulations that's
huge thank you but
but it is but then you go what if that
like in a weird way in a weird way okay
backtracking a tad bit yes so there was
a point where everyone in my camp now
I'll just say I'll just say across the
board yeah was like what the [__] are
you doing with this bird is fat thas fat
[__] it's pointless it's going nowhere
like stop ignore it you have real work
to do and I was like this I think is
going to be bigger than anything I've
ever done I trust me I think this is
going to be like this is first of all
it's fun for me I was having a lot of
fun doing it I that's the only reason to
do anything and I was like honestly dude
we could have been accountants me and
you could have made a lot of money in
sales could I want to have more fun than
that I said I'm having fun with it it's
inspiring me I am working out I am
losing weight I am feeling better about
myself every day I'm posting a video I'm
gaining followers and I was like [__] it
like I'm I'm not going to do that and
then I at once point someone called my
wife and was like hey you need to like
uh get bird to [__] drop this like he
needs to he needs to be focusing on a
sitcom I'm should be working on but I
was like he needs to focus on the sitcom
and I was and Lan's like oh you don't
know Bert but but we have we have a very
incestuous
like my wife is definitely a part of my
career awesome like she goes to General
meetings not to like with like networks
but like when my agents and managers
have a meeting my wife
goes she's like oh you don't know Bert
this is if he's interested in something
this is what he's going to be doing mhm
and then
arguably this thing is what the fans got
interested in we do two days of Rogan
which I can only guess what the numbers
of those were oh
millions millions yeah Joe Rogen buil an
Empire bigger than
like I'll
say bigger than any television show I
could have done 100% bigger than how
crazy is that bigger than any radio show
or television show I the greatest thing
ever isn't that crazy and all his fans
are cool too on top of it and they're
[__] cool and they get it and they're
and they and they they're they love
something like this where two of the
comics they've known for five or six
years yeah are really friends and are
really breaking balls and are really
having fun and are really trying to
inspire each other to be better better
versions of themselves and it's like
that it's everything it's perfect storm
I think yes and I think that's the
future I think I think
podcasting's and social media has
changed the game dude my podcast gets
bigger numbers than my TV shows ever got
that's incredible I know I mean not
actually I should rephrase that not the
first two seasons of birth conquer but
definitely the last seasons of anything
I just did my podcast is bigger that's
awesome and so
so uh anyway so that the Wilbur sells
out only because of all this fun [__] I
was doing not the [__] business [__]
no it's all about fun and that's the
weirdest thing about like you know the
one cool thing about podcasting is it's
genuinely ours like no one's got
anything no producer notes nobody
messing it up no one and I and I am
sometimes rude to people in my like on
my team when they imply that they know
something something about this at all
yeah like like I said to someone we were
talking about
something and he was like well you know
is there any way you know I I can't say
it really without like like the whole
point is like managers and agents don't
get a percentage of your ad sales and
then I was saying I was saying look not
to be disrespectful but like they don't
they have absolutely no idea what goes
into a podcast so like defin
if they want to stop by at the end of
the night and edit my podcast and post
it for me I'll I'll give them a
percentage Yeah but like I'm booking it
I'm [__] host I'm scheduling it I'm
plugging the mics in I'm running to the
the store to get new mics if my mic goes
sh if I have four people running and get
another mic yeah I'm the one worried
about about batter I'm the one watching
the levels I'm the one has to conduct
the interview and figure out where the
interview is going to go now luckily I
think my podcast is a no-brainer so
people I don't think come over with any
agenda I mean I think most podcasts are
no-brainers but like that's what I think
but honestly I think that's what people
love about that's what listeners love
about it it's not like Marin and Joe
probably have to do some research yeah
cuz they get like real guests on I just
like to hang out with my friends and
give the gift of my friends to everybody
listening does that make sense 100% it's
like let's just hang out buddy what I
what I the one thing we provide is we're
like hey man we got an insight to some
of the coolest people in town absolutely
cuz for years I I realized that was my
paycheck when I was starving at The
Comedy Store and it dawned on me I was
at the O back door and I was like oh
this is why I'm here it's to hang out
with the coolest people in the world
dude that
is when I first started and I was making
25 bucks a night at the Boston Comedy
Club I was like yeah but every night I
get a free ticket to see Chappelle atel
Jim Norton Judith freedland like all
these great Comics Pete Corelli Jim
Brewer all these guys would just stop in
and do sets so cool Lou CK your friends
Frank yeah well those two didn't but but
no but say I'd say I'm friendly with Lou
like if I ran into him we'd talk for
probably like 5 minutes and then you
know which is a great [__] it's a
great gift but that is the cool thing
about podcast so but by my thing is like
agents and managers I mean I think you
know there's there are some companies
that have figured out how to U
monetize these man Agency managers like
I took a meeting I think in my old
agency they were like so we're going to
going to blow your mind we've got you a
meeting with norm ptis and I was like
great I was like who is he and he's like
uh Courtside media podcast one they're
like he is revolutionizing podcasting
and in my head I was like what's his
podcast yeah cuz you have to have a
podcast to revolutionize podcast yeah
and they're like no no no no no no he
has he starting a an advertising company
to help monetize podcast and I was like
very interesting cuz everyone wants to
monetize their podcast y so we go into
the podcast and the deal they offered
was like we get 50% of your ad sales and
in my head I was like right now I'm
getting 100% of them yeah like why would
I give you 50% yeah getting 100% And
then he was like but we like it was the
things he was saying and no disrespect
to Norman this is the early days so he
maybe I'm sure his his views have
changed yes but he was like he was like
here's the deal say you're in uh
Minnesota on the road you want to do a
podcast you call me up I got a studio
for you right away you just bam they put
in the card they send us the file we get
it uploaded we post it and I was like as
opposed to just having the person come
to my hotel room cuz that's right now
what I do and I just I plug in all my
and I was like oh I don't think he's
aware that it's become changed and I was
like I was like oh I have an h4n and he
was like you don't even need to worry
about those and I was like huh I was
like I was so lost and I was looking at
CIA I was like this is the this is the
deal I was like oh no no no no CIA wants
piece of this I guarantee you they have
a deal so now I'm giving CIA 10% I'll
give my manager 10% because it came
through CIA my business manager gets 5%
my lawyer gets 5% my so now I get 20% of
my ad sales are you [__]
me [__] you that's crazy you're out of
your [__] mind if you think that I'm
going to do something for 20% of the
money I I would I just won't do podcast
I'll do television
yeah g that really kind of upset me and
it's upset a lot of people do you know
what I think it is I think it's that
business people can recognize that this
is like a game changer podcasting all
like what we were just talking about
this immediate connection with everybody
and we don't
need a huge gatekeeper to make it happen
Technology's flattened it out yeah and I
think they go okay well this is the next
big thing how do we make money from it
and that that's it they just they just
don't they don't have it figured out yet
and I kind of think that's what makes it
cool it's like right now everybody's
kind of in It For the Love of the Game
and it helps us I think comedians are
early adapters because like I don't make
advertising money my podcast is small my
numbers aren't great but I love the
people that listen to it and when I go
to Edmonton there'll be 20 people there
that weren't going to be there anyway
and then it's not like I expect them to
just come to a show it's like they know
me so I'm like dude let's go get it and
we get food and they're like dude
brought you this and like this year at
The Comedy Store they were like dude
you've got more Christmas presents here
than famous comedians and it's awesome
stuff people get me like 87 Tops
baseball cards Ric Flair pictures a guy
came down to San Diego this weekend and
just knows me just knows me and he
brought me a cool hat he was like he was
walking down the street and he saw a
cool hat that he wanted a Padre's hat
that's really hard to get a hold of yeah
and he went in and said they had their
size and they said no all we have is an
eight and he goes bate I'll buy it I'll
give it to Bert that's awesome and I was
like dude this is the coolest [__]
hat I've owned for and I'm like I'm a
hat guy yeah me too he knows that and
he's like he's like hey man I thought
you'd enjoy this and I was like dude
you'll be seeing this hat everywhere
like cuz when I get a hat I wear the
[__] out of it yeah dude I got my old
school Don Carlos hat right here I love
hats like uh and so but it is crazy how
they know you that's the one creepy
thing like you'll say something and
you'll be like dude I have to stop
giving away ideas on my podcast I'm like
oh I want to write a movie about this I
want to do and then people were like hey
dude I started working on that idea you
were talking about I was like part of me
goes wouldn't it be nice if you just
gave away an idea and then the guy was
like hey man you know I wrote the idea
would you like to partner with me and
you're like [__] yeah yes you do all the
work you want to do the grown-up
stuff I'm starting to learn that yeah I
like like how to like really write
scripts and that makes me feel good the
only thing I've learned about in
podcasting is not to talk [__] about
people although I just did that pretty
aggressively at the beginning of this
like I don't I'm not talking [__] about
Norm ptis everyone knows knows Norm p'
business structure I just I'm just and I
think anyone who's doing nor working
with Norm who isn't Adam Corolla you
know or isn't Adam's people yeah and
Adam's a great [__] guy I'm not
[__] on Adam I know I think Adam's a
part of podcast one but Adam helped
create that business Paradigm look Adam
set up the entire concept of podcasting
for us yeah in a in in a large portion I
think it was him Marin and Rogan I
completely agree are the [__]
founding fathers of podcasting yes and
Adam's the guy that said it doesn't have
to be in your man cave it can be a job
you can do this for a living you can and
I mean Adam's got his own little [__]
I I call a pirate ship but it's like his
spot he's got his [__] Warehouse
where all his cars are they do movies
out of there they do everything I would
love that that is my dream that is my my
genuine [__] dream is to have a
office right around the corner like
right in these Office Buildings or
somewhere cool yeah and and have like
two young kids who can who I can call up
in the morning and go hey can you set up
a green screen I have an idea hey can
you set up um can you I'm I got some
video I shot last night can you edit it
up that's my other problem is I'm really
bad at giving notes that's why I do
everything myself I'm really bad at
giving notes so um but that's my dream
but I'm so I'm not [__] on Norm
everyone knows his business you if
you're Stone Cold Steve Austin I'm not a
guy I want to [__] on but I'm saying
right ston Cold Steve Austin now has a
very successful podcast that wasn't
happening with Stone Cold by himself
someone needed to come into stone cold
and be like we've got it set up you
don't have to do anything just show up
and be yourself yeah you know what
though I remember years ago this was
literally year like probably like three
years ago Gabriel glacius went on Stone
Cold's podcast and he did it at his
house really yeah here's the thing and I
was so impressed with like sometimes
it's difficult if I love somebody's art
for me to be objective about the person
I admit that about me CU I love Stone
Cold like okay love him I love Stone
Cold Steve Austin in a way that's
unhealthy like yes like dude so that so
he was and more like gab's like do you
want to come to Stone Cold's house I was
like yes you went with him yes that's
how cool Gabriel is and stone cold at
his H forn dude he had literally Pages
pages of handwritten notes on gab's
career
he did all his you serious dead serious
ladies and gentlemen I'd like to retract
any statement I said about Steve Stone
Cold Austin so inaccurate that's the
problem with me also is I say things not
knowing what the [__] I'm talking about
so ignore everything I just said this
whole podcast so Uncle Steve Austin had
notes on
his notes and the best questions he was
just so cool God dang it see I wouldn't
like I asked Gabe to be on my podcast
and he said no and uh I think he he just
so busy I just well yeah I know I think
I think it it first of all it came from
a third party and he said yes to the
third party and then replied back he's
like I don't have time man I'm sorry
yeah I feel bad asking anybody for stuff
like I feel horrible I don't feel bad
asking Gabe because I don't really know
him I've only met him a couple times he
seems like a really sweet guy you know
and so I don't have a problem asking
someone like that oddly enough but I
would have a problem like like I I asked
Rogan one time and he was like way too
busy and I was like cool and then I'm
sure I should have asked him again but
I'm just like you know what yeah I I
feel the same way about Joe like he's so
I asked Brewer one time and Brewer was
like I'm super busy I was like good good
good not that I'm not saying I'll never
ask you again but it's just I I
appreciate that you said no I'm never
going to put you in that situation again
that's I don't want to like I had asked
Joe to do to help with one of my charity
shows cuz he was like Hey whenever and I
was like well we're going to be doing
one and he was like okay and then I felt
bad because like I couldn't get in touch
with them and then somebody else did and
I'm like just stop I don't like if he
can do it great if not that's the other
thing is that sometimes you
like I hate asking I never want to make
people feel bad I hate asking and then I
go and then other people go well don't
worry I'll just like a manager or agent
go I'll just reach out to him I go no no
don't do that do not do that don't ever
like I had a I had someone reach out to
Doug Benson one time yeah and Doug
Benson called me he was like please
don't ever give my number to any of
those [__] people and I was like I
did not yeah and he was like what I was
like I never gave your number to anyone
they just reached out I don't know how
they got your number but it was not me
don't give [__] numbers out I don't
give anyone's number out to anyone no
Nei other one I gave I I the other day
di did Dr Drew and his wife Susan's
podcast back to back I said you guys
should really do pushing Tom's podcast
CHR Christina and Tom sigura uh their
podcast and vice versa or at least have
them come over and do your respective
podcast and Drew was like fantastic I'd
love that I'm sitting with Tom I tell
him that I go is it cool if I give your
number to Drew and he's like of course
of course but but if had I done it maybe
he would have freaked out and I go I go
can you ask push if it's cool and he
reach out to push he goes yes and then I
have to reach to Drew and Susan is it
okay if I give your numbers cuz I'm like
I cannot just assume I'm right there
with you by the way by the way I I am
total opposite if you gave my number to
anyone I'd be like oh cool man that's
how well thank God that's why I love
cell phones yeah cuz I'm like oh if I
don't recognize a number I just don't
pick it
up oh I didn't yeah I did that yesterday
I didn't I didn't answer a lot of
numbers and then I answered a number on
on a podcast and it was my cardiologist
with my test results and I was like a
man don't want to air this live it's
going to be bad news it's like liver
elevated uh inflammation elevated but
not a concern have a great day and I was
like really not a concern's good news
not a concern is a great news that's why
I took a Xanax last night not a concern
and then I won't drink tonight we're
supposed to go over to sigur's house for
dinner but he got I love him by the way
he's he's
yeah yeah I I awesome have a special
like I you know it's I
didn't you you're very lucky at who you
meet when you first get into the
business and who you become friends with
and he's one of those guys that I just
got very lucky very lucky and I had no I
had no part in it but uh his best friend
was J Moore's assistant and I was
touring with Jay and Jay's assistant
said I'd like you to meet my buddy Tom
he wants you to be a comedian so we were
Brea and uh God how long ago was this
this was 17 years ago no it's got to
be wow hold on cuz we're in
2 cuz this had to be it had to be before
I had Isa it had to be 13 years ago 14
years ago it had to be a long time yeah
four 15 cuz I remember the first time I
saw you I had heard the legend but the
first time I saw you was remember Louis
Anderson used to host shows for bar cats
Sunday nights at The Comedy Store I
think it was 2003 that was around that
time yeah yeah and and uh man I can I
tell you to date had I never done
television y this is my theory I'm being
dead serious when I say this MH so I got
Louis one night brought me over to mity
so Mitsy could watch me mhm I was
murdering at that time in my career like
I was in a I was in a really good place
writing wise like I was just writing
very quickly and very
freely if I had passed Missy didn't pass
me she just said uh I don't she didn't
even say anything she just said no it
wasn't a dick thing she just said no and
by the way I definitely bombed in front
of her everybody does I bombed hard in
front of her that was her assistant she
told me that happens all the time oh
yeah and so but I believe had I been
passed at that moment yeah I may have a
very different career than I have today
well it's one of my favorite things to
do in life yeah and I've also given up
cuz I used to be I'm like if this
happened then this happened and now I
just say I wouldn't trade it for the
world I don't play detective with okay I
wouldn't trade it for the world cuz here
okay let's let's do sliding doors yeah
had I been past there was like there
were like
four uh Comics working the door who
pulled me aside one night and gave me
really great compliments I don't I do
not remember who anyone was it could
have easily been me very easily could
have been cuz I remember watching you I
I cuz I would work Sunday nights because
then I was like we only getting $25 a
shift but was like oh but then I'm also
already there for my spot cuz it's the
night we could perform yeah and I I
remember when Louie booked that show
with Barry cats cuz I was also working
in the day for Paulie and I remember
when they came in and I was like oh
these are going to be a lot of New York
guys that I haven't seen so I would sit
on the stool Steve Burn me Jay Moore
would do it Bill bur i w I literally
walked Bill Burr from the main room into
the o with Barry cats and I said put
them
up not that he needed but they were like
no cuz store was weird then it was it
was a different place totally it was a
really different place and but and I'll
say this now I say my career would be in
a different place it could be worse yeah
cuz I think also at that time I had met
my wife we were dating yeah had I moved
over the store I would have all my I may
I mean I was also doing home run derby I
think at the time with reney and Ari and
Brett Ernst and Sebastian and I remember
being like and and Amed was like you
need to be working at the store and
Steve was you need to be working at the
store that that's that whole period of
time I think I would have gotten into
drugs a little harder yeah I definitely
would have gotten into drugs harder I
probably would have and I think there
was a period of time where some of those
guys not the ones I mentioned there's
more that I haven't mentioned but we
don't need to name names some of those
guys were doing stand up for [__] as
opposed to doing stand up for the art
100% so and I think I would have fallen
into that group very quickly because
there was a time in New York where I
realized oh [__] stand up can get you
laid and I just hung out with a bunch of
stand up for [__] guys yeah and that
was our Mo was like [__] I'd bring in
hot girls off cuz I work the door so I
bring in hot girls I'd sit them in great
seats I'd make sure that the other
Comics knew they were there [__]
these just give you heads up they're
from Liverpool just giving like you know
like so we could work material around
how to [__] themar and I definitely did
but and then I remember saying to Rogan
one time I go I go
man I forgot what I said but I said
something like I'm glad I got into the
store now and not you know 12 years ago
or 10 years ago when I first came by
here and just you know Rogan is just so
matter of fact sometimes he just goes
yeah we wouldn't be friends I said what
he goes we would definitely not be
friends and I was like had I started
working here 10 years ago he's like yeah
I promise you and I was like I was like
yeah cuz I I was such a different guy I
was and I I and it like I think I met
him as a as a grown man which is a very
different way to meet meet men like when
you like I got kids I got I got kids I
got a house don't you know I'm a growing
up also like I I I I have my own career
I do my own [__] I'm gonna come to you
as like a sounding board for advice I've
done that with him and Bill I used to do
it with J Moore but I do it with him and
Bill like just run you know like you've
get you get they've just lived a very
different life like I got off for the
man show they want to do a reboot of The
Man Show and they came to me and they're
like we want you to reboot the man show
they're like you and pick your co-host
and I was like really and they're like
yep and and I was like wow I was like
wow this is a dream scenario yeah and I
called Rogan and he goes do not do it I
was like really he goes don't do it man
he goes he goes I don't think it's I
don't think you're ever going to make
the product that Jimmy and Adam had no
one will see it in their eyes the same
way and he was like and it just did was
not easy for me and it didn't help me my
career and he's like I'm just telling
your friend don't do it and I was like
and I passed and but I passed I passed
cuz I was having trepidation 2o and they
wanted me to get Bill burd a co-host and
I was like guys bill burd is not doing
the man show with me I can promise you
that and they're like what about sigura
and I called seura and seura passed he
was like ah I think I'm going to pass I
don't know man but I was doing it cuz I
was like a lot of money Big Brand yeah
you know like I like I see the other
side of Television where I go it'll
it'll get I'll get to do all my ideas
and Stan hope is like you're not going
to do your ideas that's another guy I
call for business like more like life
advice I I call I call them all for like
different [__] like different facets
of the same problem seur I call sgura
for like advice like because there's so
few people that can give you real like
detached advice yes like if you called
me right now and you're like I'm
thinking about doing a show for Travel
Channel I'd be like oh [__] do it
it'll be a blast like it'll be a blast
you're going to love it it's going to be
the funnest [__] year of your life
but and now if you said hey they offered
me a seven-year contract I'll be like
all right now we should talk because for
seven years you're going to be in a
holding pattern in life where you won't
be able to do stand up the way you want
to do it and if you do you're going to
be breaking your [__] back to get
both done and uh but man it's I I would
still say do it it's such a fun [__]
time yeah I would love to do something
fun like that it's there's a lot of jobs
that you know and I that I look at and I
go you know you you could have your
dream job anyone can have their dream
job it's so easy you just got to say I'm
just going to do it and then commit to
it and be one of those guys like
like I wish I think of the guy that does
this like Steve Burn Steve Burn's a I
love him all my chips in this pot kind
of guy yeah he just decides to do
something and then he does it yeah he's
so focused he just does it he goes I
want a sitcom y I want a sitcom like
cheers but in Pittsburgh with me and my
buddies and and like very like I'm not
saying that Steve is a simple person but
very simple in his wants and needs where
he
goes this is what I want I know that I
want that that and if I want it then I
need it so I'm just going to make it yes
and I won't stop no one's telling me no
and I I am blown away by that like he
just he's just very focused on that like
he's very good at that yeah he's really
like like admirable dude he's a guy yeah
I do admire him because he does get [__]
him all the time when we just sent him a
script last night oh he's the best he is
the best and really solid to his friends
yes loyal very loyal what's the word
integrity do we have a good crew we
travel like all probably probably the
probably I'm not okay I'm not [__]
around and this is going to be the
biggest statement I've ever said yeah in
the history of Comedy that for comedy's
ever been around we have the tightest
best group of comedians working right
now this is the best comedy's ever been
across the board meaning there's a lot
of friendships involved there's not a
lot of bickery there's not a lot of
hating not not a lot of people hate
people like you look at like you look at
like big J comes out to the store and do
nothing but love nothing but love
[__] Jim Norton comes out to the
store everyone's [__] excited to see
him y you know and I think I think part
has to do with podcasting but like
there's very few people in this business
right now that no one that no one that
everyone's like yeah and we've kind of
smoked them out smoked them out it's
beautiful you know what I think part of
it really is what the Love of the Game I
think we we are the generation that
there was no money in standup like
people don't realize I remember talking
to a door guy at the comedy store in
2001 when I started to work there Harris
I don't know if you ever met Harris but
he har Harris Pete he'd been doing
comedy since the 70s yeah and he was
telling me how much money comedians made
say in 1982 he was like Steve there were
limited clubs but they were starving for
Comics you can make $1,500 a week plus a
plane ticket to feature in 1982 hly I'm
like
dude we make less money now 30 years
later here do me a favor we grab that
[__] phone so we don't have to hear
that yeah I don't know how to do it it's
just just lift it up I'm
sorry here throw it to me I'm gonna I'm
GNA just so I can sorry but that yeah
that you know when I started my first
headlining tour was um
was uh
$1,300 to
headline uh $300 for travel Y and uh and
they'd put you in the condo yeah
and we would 13 dates and I thought I
was [__] Rich exactly like nobody did
and there was no TV there was no comedy
movies being made there was no comedy TV
shows being made there was no like oh
you do The Tonight Show and you get a
development deal and all that was gone
see I was there at the beginning of that
I was there very not The Tonight Show
but I was there at the very tail end I
was talking with Gareth Reynolds and
Dave Anthony about this D I'm gonna get
Gareth on the podcast I love that dude
[__] amazing yeah um but I was saying
that I was in the last generation of
development deals the last group of guys
that got development deals I would say
the last ones were me uh Frank kando and
chicken wow Gary Gman the three of us
got the last round of development deals
wow for the four of us and uh of young
comics and then they disappeared because
uh because they all flopped and everyone
wasted you know over a million dollars
on talent that quite honestly was going
to be there anyway it's not like we were
going anywhere they could have just cast
Us in anything anyway
yes and
so then I mean Gary I mean Last Comic
Standing saved comedy in a weird way
yeah because was a little Bridge it it
was the only thing that kept us afloat
or got people interested in us because I
remember Gary Goldman and I sitting Dane
Cook Last Comic Standing Dane Cook is
there's a lot of credit that can be
given to Dane because you know he just
reintroduced a way to do it ourselves
that we're still doing yeah but he was
that first
first it's you know what frustrates me
about danne is that I wish he had just
never I I wish he had never gotten
sidetracked by the business and stayed
akin to his passion of like technology
and doing it his own way and making his
own products and [__] reinvesting his
money in himself yeah I like the he got
I think he got that siren temptress
whistle from the the hor in the ocean
being like okay great glad you got here
with
Myspace understand Facebook's taking off
that's all horeshit what really matters
is you and Jessica Simpson and and it's
really hard to say no it's really hard
to go oh yeah I won't do a movie I won't
I won't do [__] five movies I won't
sell out a stadium right I I I don't
know I I think he probably made so much
money yeah oh yeah so much money that I
think it's
difficult if you're not no matter who
you are or how you made it or cuz like
the way you see athletes act the way I
think there's just something about an
obscene amount of money that makes it
very difficult to hold on to your
Humanity but but think about this had
DNE taken that money done the couple
projects taken that money reinvested in
himself he could wrote any movie stay
with technology kept making his own
stuff Dan by the way Dane was making all
his own stuff he was making
shorts what the
[__] he was making shorts he was making
all his own stuff had he done that do
you know who he'd be Kevin Hart oh yeah
that's what Kevin Hart did Kevin Hart
got got money [__] it do another tour
I'm gonna I'm gonna pay for it I'm going
to put it out in theaters [__] it I'm
GNA take this I'm gon to start my own
busy Heartbeat Productions so [__] this
I'm going to do this I'm going to make
my own [__] and just kept reinvesting in
himself and and I mean I mean I I can't
even I can't even Kevin Hart's a genius
I don't know if he's a genius or if he's
just like Steve Burn where he just goes
no no no I'm gonna do what I want to do
I'm gonna make my own thing yeah I like
I'm not saying Kevin a genius I don't
think he's he's definitely business
business savvy but but like I don't know
if he's a genius other than he just goes
he just says the same thing that Dan say
was like it works for
me working for me works for me I'm the
only one this passionate about me I'm
just going to keep doing my own [__] I I
mean I think that's what Kevin has done
because he just does his own [__] and he
stays in his Lane you know like like he
gets passionate about something he goes
[__] it if I'm passionate about it
passion begets passion other people get
passionate about it that's like [__]
this workingout kick is on like I kind
of I kind of find it fun because I go
now I'm on a little bit of a workout
kick and so I kind of just keep up with
where he's at and I was like I'm not
saying Kevin har got me healthy but like
I definitely look at him and I go yeah
man he really is killing it in the gym
yeah you know like that is Darren
Carter's doing that to me right now have
you seen Daren Carter's workout updates
no to the party starter there's a boxing
gym in Burbank Pullman's yeah dude I
remember when Darren started there like
a year and a half ago now he's drink my
microphone he's doing like 300 push-ups
a day 300 squats a day running six miles
jumping ropes
sparring it it's inspirational I had um
yeah I
I I there's this business I don't know
if it's CU I've I've been drinking less
and working out more and I my self
self-esteem good for you yeah it's
definitely my self-esteem was so [__]
low when this whole fat shaming thing
started my self-esteem was in the
[__] [__] like I remember I was
talking about therapy I was like I had
to I had to find out the difference
between ego and self-esteem because I'd
look at someone like Kevin Hart and it
would make me depressed I was like how
can he be so [__] up you know what
it's all a lie no one can be that
positive there's no [__] way and then
and then when I started losing weight
like I didn't do it healthy obviously
like I jump start my diet with like a
Xanax at 4: a at 4 p.m. and then sleep
wait like wake up like I did last night
like I did last night honestly like I
did last night like I was just telling
you that's how I jump started a diet
except I use an ambient in the middle so
like so what I did is I took a Xanax at
like 4: and then slept and then or woke
up and was like had dinner with my but I
didn't eat cuz I was a little tired had
double Tito soda went right back to bed
woke up in the morning had an ambient
slept all [__] day that night woke up
for dinner with my family couple
cocktails back in bed Monday morning I
am like 13 lbs down wow no [__] and then
once you're 13 lb down you're like
that's momentum you're like this is
momentum now we're now we're moving
somewhere so
um but but that's the most unhealthy
advice to give anyone no one listen to
what I said but uh and then I started
feeling feeling better about myself and
I was like oh I feel good like I deserve
good things like I deserve that is the
secret to all of it yeah people feel
unworthy we all don't feel good enough
and that's why we make poor decisions
it's the secret to all of it I was I
couldn't understand I couldn't the the
[__] the whatever it is I guess ID is
I don't know what an ID is but I think
ID is that inner wolf I think I don't
know yeah so like that's perfect way to
put it inner
wolf uh let's just call it an inner bear
because I have a more of a bear
mentality of like a big dumb animal but
my inner bear would hibernate at times
when I was overweight or I was drinking
a lot or I was like smoking a lot of pot
yeah um my inner bear would hibernate
hard as [__] and then in times like this
where you're feeling good your inner
bear starts roaring well what and then
like when I was getting fat shamed my
inner bear would be protective of itself
so so we'd hibernate again what I
couldn't understand and I say this I
hope this comes out from a place of love
but like Amy Schumer gets fash shamed
more than any human out there her and
Lena Dunham and I don't look I'm not a
fan of Lena Dunhams I don't like Lena
Dunham personally but like I do feel a
connection with her because I know what
it's like to get hate online and like we
all do and so I like I I may not I may
not like her political views I may not
like the way she uh like the way she
talks about stuff like abortion and like
like for me for me I used to have a joke
where I go uh I don't really have like a
I don't really have
a a view politically like like people go
oh we should ban all guns I go yeah but
they're really [__] fun like guns are
really fun like if you're an adult and
you can handle them like they're [__]
a blast out and shoot machine guns
[__] amazing it feels awesome now
yeah granted they kill a lot of people
too but but and then I was like like
abortion like listen I like I I think it
should be up to the woman's right to
choose I think the woman should choose I
don't think I should have a say in her
decision on what she wants to do and but
then I go but if you get an abortion
let's not cut it any other way you did
kill something yes kill something like
hey I'm not saying I yeah I look I agree
if you want to kill something kill
something but let's not say it's not
killing something you definitely [__]
killed something that was a [__] life
like look I would sit with that gravity
on my
yeah for the rest of my life if you can
deal with that deal with that I believe
that that what the law should be is it's
your body it's your choice but don't
forget your choice also is murder like
the green lip murder that I'm not saying
that to shame you I'm just saying that
cuz that's the facts and it's also in a
way the most loving way cuz like the
problem is people do that they make that
decision that I would never ever want to
have to make but yeah that's the it
lives with you for all our decisions
live with us forever yeah forever
actions have consequences regardless got
pregnant with Georgia when we were out
of we weren't married yeah now I was
madly in love with my wife my girlfriend
at the time who I had already bought an
engagement ring for there was no
conversation ever of what would we do
there was no conversation however there
was definitely that was looming in the
air cuz we weren't married yeah like so
what do like how do you feel she didn't
say like what are we gonna do how do you
feel about this yeah I was through the
[__] roof I think I'm a better dad
than I am a better husband I think I'm a
better dad than I am comic I'm a really
f [__] dad that's everything and I
was ready to be a dad and I wanted more
kids yeah
but that was in there and I definitely
I'm not saying I toyed with the idea but
you definitely go that is in in this
moment that's the two things you talk
about yeah and I I just personally
personally I will tell you from my
experience I can't imagine doing that
now my adversely my dude honestly the
older I get the more I feel awful about
birth control I know that sounds crazy
but I'm like but I go I feel awful about
jacking off a because I go those are my
babies right like that I go I I made a
joke I go as a grown man when I jack off
and I just blow a load on a towel I go
oh my God he would have had my eyes
that's hilarious and then and then the
new joke I have that is so funny but I
feel the same way I'm like oh my gosh
cuz I want to be dad I want to be a dad
more than anything in life oh it's so
great last night we got in bed uh the
four of us um we eat dinner and then I
go hey let's all just [__] no
electronics let's just all get in bed
and talk the best four of us get in our
bed and it was the greatest it was the
greatest [__] moment you know I don't
know I think I'm having the older I get
the more I I start my eyes are open to
like to
like you know what is important you know
and I I wish I could like start a I wish
I could start a charity for like for
like families who could who just just to
like like the UN homeless people I think
they're already taken care of but
there's like a there's like a portion of
families in this country that it's like
they don't get to slow down because
they're just living paycheck to paycheck
I would love to start a charity for
families that are just a little a little
overextended where they're not
comfortable and they don't get to relax
because they're so stressed out money
yes I agree with you it's like it's like
like the one group where I go like I I
don't have that's 90% of America I've
been there before a lot robs you with
the joy of life and I don't I don't have
that this month I don't have that this
month I and I haven't had it for a
little while but I don't I definitely
don't have it that's all I can say is I
don't have it this month Y and because I
don't have that I can slow down and I
can really enjoy my daughters and go hey
you guys want to go on a bike ride and
I'm not on a bike ride going [__] man I
should call that guy back how do I angle
this how do I work this cuz I've been
there where you're like where you're
like when I when like not to get into
great details but when a show gets
cancelled and you wonder does anyone
ever want to work with me again yeah
where's my next meal coming from there's
so much uncertainty in this life like I
that's the charity I would make but like
yeah anyway you can do that by the way
by if you've had an abortion and you're
and you're thinking Bert you don't know
what it's like you're right I don't know
what it's like I don't I'm not assuming
to put my sh in anyone's shoes I'm just
telling you from my perspective and by
the way it was meant to be a joke in the
first place and just never
worked because when you accuse people of
murdering children on stage it doesn't
come out right Chris Rock had a I
remember reading this I don't know 10 12
years ago but he talked about the best
standup comedy is like mixing
nitroglycerin he goes if it's off just a
little bit it blows up in your face dude
and then the example he used was
abortion and I remember he had that joke
where he was like I survived the womb
[__] straight out of the womb like it
was prison like yeah I made it through
Patrice O'Neal was amazing at that yeah
he had a joke I I don't know if he ever
recorded it but his joke was um it was
right when Michael J fox came out with
uh Parkinson's Parkinson's okay yeah is
that what he's got yeah Parkinson's and
he's like um he's like
man I was watching this [__] news
conference
and Michael J fox is coming out saying
we need to cure
Parkinson's and he's sitting next to
Muhammad Ali and here he is trying to
[Music]
outshone person in that audience would
be like yo Michael Jay I understand uh
that we should get money to parkon but
what about AIDS and cancer and he goes I
just would like Michael J Michael J fox
just in one moment of Honesty go well
the problem with that is I don't got
that [__] and it was like but it was
like you know so brand new that Michael
J fox had Parkinson's and so many people
grew up with him as their older brother
and so many people loved him in every
show he's ever done and he's never been
a guy that beat up women or anything
he's such a [__] Canadian American
treasure that like Michael J fox from
Canada oh [__] yeah God I love Canadians
yeah oh dude can I tell you about Allan
thick uh Allan thick I was on a I was on
a plane flying to I want I don't I'm
going to guess New York only because it
was sleeper beds and I was sitting I got
upgraded in sleeper
and Robin Thick was flying with his dad
which I already find coolest [__] that
you're hanging out with your dad yes and
they got up and these people that were
like my age asked Alan Thick if they
could take a picture with them and his
son and he was so proud like ear to ear
he was like of course of course and he
like got their camera and took like
probably seven pictures with Robin Thick
and and and there was no and in my head
I was like I was like dude you're my dad
from growing up when boner and [__]
Richard stabone the hot tub one dude
when they went in the hot tub and the
lady offered them cocaine yes changed my
life I was like I am never doing drugs
that that the ratings for that must have
been through the [__] roof do you
know who boner was Richard stabone no no
a little sidebar of
interesting Jimmy parto is married to
boner sister no way yeah now the reason
I love Jimmy Paro Jimmy Paro is [__]
great but but Jimmy Paro but uh not to
take this in a sad Direction um I'm
right now I cannot remember his real
name and it's escaping me and I know it
cuz his dad was check off on Star Trek
boner dad was check off on Star Trek
it's a lot of talent in one family yes
and uh and then they brought parto
and no but uh but um and then he had
some me issues he had some I think
bipolar issues or depression issues and
he um ended up I think committing
suicide but he worked on he worked on
never not funny he was on the show all
the time I I can't remember I can't
believe I can't remember his name right
now and it's bothering me wow um but uh
but yeah
so um I don't know what we were talking
about we were talking about uh you were
talking about abortion and how petrice
made the Parkinson yeah oh but that
you're right and that led more into like
family type Chris Ro Chris rocks nword
ver black people versus nword it's
iconic but you know that I heard that
bombed a lot and and that you
know
that let's okay let's try to size it up
the seminal bits of our career the ones
that you go that's the best bit written
mhm that has to be that might be number
one it's up there okay so Bill and Louie
have to have a couple yeah Bill's got
see the dude I think Bill's the best I
I'm not just saying this cuz we know him
I hate saying that because I know Bill
doesn't want that said I know Bill's
like Bill's like I'm not I'm just
working just like you I have hard times
just like you and I'm I'm like yeah but
you're writing so much quicker than I am
and I go and and then part of me goes
I'm not you know at the best I am in my
game I'm I'm obsessive compulsive about
standup and that which is not enjoyable
like I can't let go of the bit like I
[__] I'm obsessing about bits and I'm
like and everything's a bit every every
turn around the corner and I'm like
there's no way this many bits are coming
into my life but like uh but Bill's one
bit from his special about adopting um a
a sweat Factory kid versus uh a Boy
Soldier is one of my favorite bits I've
ever heard um
Louie you know I'm trying to think of
something Lou I mean I think Lou's one
line that he created that made itself
into the lexon Lexicon is suck a bag of
dicks yep like that's just one of those
things where you're like oh now everyone
says that you're like oh and Lou came up
with that yes I don't know if there's
any another bit as good as black people
versus and wordss I think for me my
favorite bit ever is probably kennison's
this is
sand that's a that yep okay that licking
the alphabet was a was one yeah can
where you're like yeah Kennison was
pretty okay dice's Hickory Dickory Dock
his nursery rhymes might that might be
the number one bit it's amazing dude and
then Eddie Murphy like just you could
pull about just about anything off of
yeah h h h you ain't got no ice cream
like dude Eddie Murphy dude Eddie Murphy
another force of nature yeah and when
you think about how young he was when he
was doing that stuff J can can I tell
you and I think Eddie Murphy's a genius
so do I and I think Charlie
Murphy is you know he came into stand up
is such a late time in the game he is
one of the most naturally funny human
beings you ever you ever get into like a
spiral where you just watch Charlie
Murphy no Charlie Murphy I'm gonna I'll
check him out on YouTube Hold on so
Charlie Murphy's got this story that I
heard on Snoop dogs podcast it's so good
and he's like uh and I think Snoop says
what was it like being Eddie Murphy's
brother he's like yo man like I'm doing
a bad Charlie Murphy but he's like it
was great he was like I came back from
the Navy and my brother's in LA and it's
just a different world he goes I came
back all I had was my uniform wow and
the first night Eddie's like yo we're
going out he's like go into my closet
and grab something to wear and I come
out and they're all
like leather jackets no shirts leather
pants then [__] Sparkles he's like
I'm out of the Navy so I go into the by
the way I'm punching this story up from
the way I remember it yes but but this
is the story so I go into the
closet and like and I grab a pair of
like sparkl pants and a bus boy jacket
you guys you remember the bus boys they
were a band yeah they played on a
special the boys they did a song on H
Ghostbusters too and he's like it was
like a it was like up above like it
stopped right above your your Naval and
it was like striped with sparkling and
like all the stripes were were sparkling
he's like we go in this club and he's
like I walk in and I feel like a
mil he's like he goes I can hear people
talking like yo yo yo that's Eddie
Murphy that's Eddie Murphy and they're
like yo who's that he's with and he's
like yo that's his brother and he's and
he's like I'm yeah and they're like
man what what's his brother do like I
think he's a
magician [__] ruined that bit but it
was I was it Charlie Murphy is the
[__] naturally funniest person
magician I think he's a magician that's
the funniest thing I've ever heard I
think he's a
magician I [__] wish I was friends
with him like I wish I could hang out I
he's a lot older than me like I think
he's like 70 who cares I would love to
hang out with him he just makes me laugh
I watch so much [__] I watched all the
outtakes from Chappelle show of like his
just outakes where can you find that
stuff online and I'll just type in
Charlie Murphy and watch everything I've
ever done he was friends he told a story
on Rogan where he was friends with uh uh
a a singer Johnny Johnny Gil Johnny Gil
really Johnny from New Edition Johnny
Gill one night decided he wanted to be a
prize
fighter and he just tells his story of
Johnny Gill wanted to be a prize it was
the funniest [__] he's like I think I
could beat up Mike Tyson uh dude Charlie
Murphy is someone that I would like I
would I would maybe I'll reach out to
him and see if I can get him on my
podcast I he but but all I do is I have
him tell all the stories I want to hear
cuz like I just I he made me laugh so
hard you know Tom saguro was really good
friends with Charlie Murphy and I mean
him and Joe Rogan and Charlie Murphy
like were like buddies like they hung
out all the time sigura won this uh
Maxim Real Men of Comedy contest yeah
and so they let him open in like two
cities for uh hefron sigura or for heon
Rogan and yeah I remember that that was
like 2005 maybe 2006 yeah what I'll tell
you Charlie Murphy had just started
standup and he was like he was like
don't worry I'll close and Rogan's like
what he's like yeah I'll close yeah I
know I would never want to follow Rogan
let alone having done it a year I yeah
never Charlie Murphy I I just find him
really [__] fascinating he's also old
school you know like it's great I
remember Brennan tell me the story like
I forget how he knew Charlie him and no
they knew they were going to put him on
the show before that because he those
stories he said they just naturally
would flow out and you know what it's
the thing about storytelling it's
sometimes I don't know for me I think I
don't I'm not I'm not like Charlie
Murphy Charlie Murphy's got such a slow
pace and the way he talks is so
interesting yes and like he can get into
character and get in and out of
character I I I Charlie Murphy really is
one of those people that his
storytelling is so good and so organic
it almost doesn't belong on stage like I
don't know if a stage would appreciate
it the way you can when you hear it
third party and he's just telling it
oneon-one you know gotcha like I don't
know like I Honestly though I think
that's the best standup I think the best
standup is when it it doesn't feel like
a performance that it's just a real it's
like you're connected with the audience
it's intimate and awesome my uh I want
to do maybe I'll do it in the belly room
but like I want
to one of the problems I'm having with
this new hour is that like I've got I've
got like
two maybe
like let see if my joke book was around
I've got like two
bits I don't think I brought it with me
um I've got like two or three bits like
bits that you that like you could use
meaning like they're not they're not
specific to me okay and
then I've got like four stories
which by the way makes stand up very
problematic when you have like total you
have seven things for your hour I know
and you're like oh I don't have like a
million different things I can go to I
think it's better though I think this is
the stuff people want to I think but I
think I'm going to do I'm going to do
just stories where I tell I I I need to
tell the tra the Travel Channel stuff I
got to figure it out I was thinking
about writing a book I've a buddy I'm
never going to write another book by
myself I'm always going to have a ghost
written or co-written with me writing it
by your is the biggest got to be like
the never ending homework it was it was
so stressful and it was so and it really
[__] me up in my head and it was a a
sincere waste of time I mean I'm glad
everyone liked the book and I'm really
proud that I did it I'm really glad I
did it
however I could have theoretically spent
just as much time if not an eighth of
that time figuring out those stories for
stage and just sharing them on stage
which I think is my my strong suit
that's why I became a standup I moved
out here cuz I wanted to be a
screenwriter yeah and then I was like I
didn't have the discipline to sit down
and do it and I went what I loved about
standup cuz I always loved standup
admired it but what I to this day what I
love most about it is when they say your
name you can't procrastinate you just
have to go out there and do it it's the
greatest and it's alive in the moment
tried I've tried um like I've tried to
get the thing that sucks is like you
just got to find
sometimes for me I get the big story and
then try to work back like I I I wanted
to do the moth and I and they said What
story do you want to tell one of the
interesting things about working for
travel channel is I came out with PTSD
like I had I because I was doing three
bucket list activities a day in three in
10 hours my go everywhere and then
sometimes at the very end of the day
getting on a plane and flying to a new
place and starting up a brand new three
and there's really really really like
specific moments where you go where you
where you recognize your the fragility
of your mortality like really I I say I
appreciate my mortality more than any
single person could possibly appreciate
the
mortality pedestrian not like [__]
thrill seeker not like you know guys who
bass jump and stuff like that but like
only because I was a regular guy put in
these extra extraordinary situations
where you're like like we're on Safari
and a lot of people have been on Safari
and I think if you go on Safari in your
head as a as a pedestrian you're like uh
you're like oh this is cool they must
have some sort of rule rules set up so
that we can't die there is no rules and
like we were 20t from a lion who's just
sitting under a tree and I remember
thinking if this lion decides to do
something we have no exit strategy yes
there's nothing we can do if he decides
to get up and walk towards us and we
start moving and he goes oh now we're
playing catch and [__] goes after us
there's nothing we do and I remember
realizing it very acutely and the people
I was with where the [__] is she going
the people I was with just didn't sense
that but I sensed it because
like I'd seen things go wrong yeah like
when you see things go wrong you you
can't get that innocence back again ever
that's what it is is the Innocence like
I ran out of air at like 90 feet in Fiji
oh my God I remember you know what's
funny is I I thought this would be a
story that I ended up telling on stage
mhm but all I have out of this story the
only thing that I have that's
interesting out of that story cuz quite
honest honestly I live there's no end to
it you're like you don't the a thing
that makes a story great is a great
ending but like there's no end to it I
wouldn't be so concerned with that cuz
this is what I think what I think it's
the ride like I'm working out a story I
told on a podcast about uh eventually
it's about me crying on a treadmill in
front of Denzel Washington and we have
to takes a while to get but people have
so much fun walking through the
experience with you that story will be
epic if you can find a tag a button at
the end
that t it yeah I have I have a way to
get out of it like it it it lands yeah
like but I Ari and I always say if you
can like so we did a storytelling night
with Sebastian and Sebastian was the
ride was so fun he's such a talented
comedian he's unbelievable but his
ending was wasn't there and it left
everyone like yeah you definitely need
an ending like he was like he was like
yeah and then uh you know you know but
if you just came with that premise about
like I know how fragile life is well and
then you you you pulled out and your
ending is you know let's celebrate the
fact that we're alive cuz like that's
everything I'm trying to get the whole
thing I'm exploring is life is a gift
life is a joy find the little joys in
life be so grateful that you're here and
that's it CU I don't think a lot of
enough people are doing that not alone
not just in comedy but in in life in
general so it's like whatever stories
that I that's how I filter everything
I'm like is it true is it positive is it
life affirming does this make people and
remind people that they're worthy of
happiness that they're worthy of Love
Like that's what I'm trying to do so I
think I I can spin endings with that
because it feeds a larger overall point
of view yeah
maybe I see what the way I see story
these days is
like at some okay this is the way I look
at story write is it epic yeah like is
it epic does it have is it worth telling
meaning like like it doesn't need need
to be epic you know in essence but like
is it worth telling in the sense of like
is it different enough yes are people
going to have similar stories like I've
told stories that are
very across the board a lot of people
could have them the birth of my first
daughter I told that story I think
everyone's got one if you have a child
you've got a birth of the story because
it so catches you off guard uh you know
and what I did in it is I tried to weave
it so it was my own ride which was great
at the end of the
day someone could tell my exact same
story and I would go you stole that and
they go no or I just did it also so the
thing I was looking for now in stories
is is it worth telling in the sense that
like does it uh does it inspire people
does it scare people does it like does
it elicit some emotion when you start it
off yes um
another thing I need in the story is I
need I need them to be curious I need
them to be like what happens next like I
want them to like like the thing about
my scuba diving story is they already
know the ending and so I could never
figure out what happens next like the
it's almost like this whole
story is
is all it is is the ride cuz you know
what happens the only thing that's okay
what I just wrote down with the note to
myself cuz and I never thought of until
we just had this moment right now yeah
was that
the the why you're telling them is just
as important as what you're telling
them yeah
so if you can figure out the why you
want to tell that Scuba Diving story it
might figure out what you're going to
tell them so that's how you find why I
want to tell
it what's the message the theme that
story has no I told it to the mo and
they were like it's pretty much one note
story there you go and I was like really
and they're like yeah I mean yeah I mean
I guess it got scary but you're fine I
was like yeah okay so
then cuz if you talked about like the
preciousness of life that you have this
because of that job you could put that
could be a oneman show you could put
together a bunch of different stories
and you could end it with the birth of
your daughter yeah I already did that on
a special but you know what I'm saying
though like that's sort of like Ed to
life
yeah I mean it's it's interesting I
don't
know I what I need is I need a
place I need I need a place where I can
do an hour worth of stories that I don't
tell on stage so that I can really go
figure these out cuz what I do now is I
just tell them on the road in bits and
pieces and they and that people are
definitely engaged but I don't have a
litmus to find out are you just engaged
cuz I've been doing really well for like
40 minutes and I just told you a story
about riding motorcycles through rice
patties in Vietnam and is that are you
just like wow I'm long for the ride you
got me you had me you had me yeah cuz
there is a point when you connect with
an audience then it's like then it it's
a different thing like I was I was
saying like I have a story about jumping
off the world's tall stadium and uh in
Africa I said it's really funny when you
do something like
that like I I'm I wouldn't say I'm
racist but man I am racist when I'm
about to jump off a stadium and you have
a black guy harness me up I go no no no
no I need a white guy for this I that's
one of the funniest things I've ever
heard I go I've never had a black guy
ever in America harness me into anything
they've NE that's not their strong suit
it's like we're going skydiving this is
your instructor Jamal you're like uh I'm
going to pass I want to I want to meet
Blake like I want to you know that's so
funny cuz black guys don't go they just
don't go skydiving they don't go surfing
they don't go [__] bungee jumping
they don't go Bas jumping
you what you see as a black guy next to
a roller coaster going [__] that [__]
like that's what the closest you see to
him so when I go to get harnessed up
I've always just had Australian guys
harness me up so they're like all right
mate here we go Zip Zap zip here we go
going to tighten up here tighten up
there pull that up on your waist would
you m okay all right now we're going to
have Dereck look at it derck you want to
take a look at it and he's like thing
there jamy and he's like okay here we go
zip Z zip we got a bob your uncle we're
ready to go and you feel safe as [__]
when a black guy does it he just goes
you're good and you're like hold on do
you want to double check your work and
he's like you think I'm lying and you're
like no no no no I'm just saying like do
you want someone else look at it and
he's
like and the guy's like and you're like
oh my God God that's got to be such an
uncomfortable feeling what's interesting
you can see it on the video is when you
jump with white people i' and I bungee
jumped a lot with white people like with
a lot with skydived with them and
they're like all right here we go going
to go on the count of three one two
three bung okay we didn't do it that
time we didn't do it that time we're
going to give it one more chance here we
go all right count of five we're going
to give you the count of five this time
when these guys did it I said all right
are we ready and they're like yeah all
right here we go and I was like are we
going to count it down and the guy goes
okay one two and he knees me in the back
and kicks me off the thing oh my gosh
him I wish I had my I do have my phone
I'll show you him Nei in the [__]
back now what he was doing cuz I I
realized it when he did it to the guy
after me he did it he kneed us all in
the
back oh shut the [__] up
what something
awesome what um I'm supposed to go to
space space what
yeah like space space
yeah yeah oh my God I just watch have
you seen that movie hidden
figures uh [__] my wife is it no no
no go see it it's like the rocky of math
it's about three black chicks
that it's one of the best movies I've
ever seen uh I get disconnected cuz I
hear that old Bill bur bit what's that
like
uh he was he was talking about I don't
even know if he did it on a special but
he was talking about um I guess there
was a movie
where black black guys were on the swim
team it's like a whole inspiration movie
it's like how [__] far are we taking
this he's like they really like don't
let them in the pool like it was like a
bit but it was really funny all right um
I'll find it in 2
seconds uh uploads should be one of my
top uploads I would imagine and dude
after this you know I would love to hear
the machine yeah I've never we have get
we talk about that yeah I would love to
tell it and in the most conversational
way possible let's see uh I got to find
man it's amazing what gets views and
what doesn't yep
um I guess these are done in these are
done chronologically here I'll show you
you got I would just want you to see the
guy kicking me off the back CU it's just
as like it just defines the difference
between black guys White and by the way
I'd love it if he didn't kick me off the
back and that's just my memory because
I'm [__] I'm in bit mode where you
like you're like that's close enough
works for the bit here we go you know
what I mean yes um Jesus Christ I went
through a period where I did a vlog and
I must have uploaded so much [__] here
we go world's tallest rope
swing I'll get to the look that's how
high we are oh my God just take a
look I never this is [__] high as
[__] [__]
never look it no time harnessing me up
just [__] clicks me in do you want to
I have a bunch of questions here I'll
get you to the part where he needs
me here did you ever figure out how to
do all this stuff yourself to double
check everybody's
work oh my
gosh yeah that's a [__] epic oh my
gosh dude I would never ever do anything
this moment right here though is the
greatest moment you'll ever have in life
when you're like I'm still alive that
moment still alive is the best moment
you'll ever have in life it's [__] I
I mean I that I couldn't tell
you I couldn't tell you how great it
feels I there's a I have a video of
something that would blow your [__]
mind I wish I had my computer in here I
have a video of me jumping off the
corona
Arch I don't even know what that is so
it's in uh Utah and it's an arch and
it's just a big like Arch coming out of
a mountain so there's like a hole
through it you know and it's I've seen
that like in in posters in college and
stuff like that so what they do is they
hook it's like a giant Stone Arch yeah
and so they hook uh they hook harnesses
into one side of it and then they drape
the Rope up under it and then harness
you into it and then when you jump you
jump out and you swing up under the
harness
come out I said to the guy right when we
did it I said uh I said maybe I should
throw on a helmet and this kid Katon
bear just looks at me and he goes you
don't want to live through this I said
what he goes if something happens man
just go just go and I was like oh my God
are you [__] kidding me I was like
I'm going to put a helmet on anyway just
in case and so then um we do it it's
successful it's one of the greatest
moments of my life and then six like 3
months later we're editing it we're
getting ready to post the the to the TV
show yeah and my producer's like setad
of curiosity okay would you go to jail
for this bit and I go what do you mean
and he's like well we kind of broke some
rules and we didn't technically get a
permit but if you're willing to do look
soft time in a federal prison federal
prison me and you will'll post it it'll
probably go viral it'll be a big story
that we go to jail and and we can we can
air it and I was like and then I started
doing the math I was like okay me and
him are big drinkers maybe 6 months we
need that it's like rehab we go in we
learn some handball we get we get some
tax advice like and I was like this
wouldn't be bad we're doing push-ups
every day we come out you know tribel
Channel's like they're out of prison
let's start the show back yes and uh and
so but we ended up my wife's like you're
not going to [__]
prison yeah that's the right decision
yeah but your wife's a good woman but I
always think it's about the story how
great would that story be yeah I just
got out of prison because of this and
then maybe that's what I should do maybe
I should use video in my in in my like
tell the story and show video up on the
screen like get clips and go let me tell
you about scuba diving in Fiji and then
you see me underwater do you know what I
this is my take just on you just out of
left field
brainstorming I would do the show you
want to show your grandkids I would talk
to the audience as if they were your
grandkids and go this is Pop BT this is
my life oh wonder if I could you know
something like that it would be too much
to do it in like and like get like an
age like no you know what I'm saying
like almost like you want them to know
you like my dad was telling me stories
about his grandparents and I'm like I
wish I could know them I wish and you're
in your Prime right now man you've had
this am cuz they're going to be talking
about you for Generations what a what a
br and it's so intimate and it's such a
good and that gives you the why do you
know how much the why there would be so
much [__] you could tell where you're
like this was black when we it was back
when we had just black people and they
weren't all
intermixed who knows I used to have just
Mexicans can you believe that they lived
in this country Donald Trump got rid of
that you could right right oh yeah you
could Wonder oh after you have all the
stories you could write as many jokes as
you want people used to judge each other
how they looked do you believe that that
would be cool if you did a whole hour
special as like an older drunk grandpa
sitting on a porch and you did like
maybe you were in makeup yeah it's one
way to do I mean I would that's a really
interesting see that's a thing that me
and you think is cool but then maybe if
I did it and you didn't do it just right
everyone be like did you see this hor
[__] right right right right right right
but I'm just saying like almost as if
it's like a time capsule like just
opening up your life and the lessons you
learned I well I was when I was talking
about writing that book I went through
and I found uh why' my assistant put uh
all the pictures from the entire four
seasons of trip flip on a drive so that
I can flip through them and there are a
lot of boring pictures but one of the
things that's great about it is it jars
my memory of all the [__] I did yes like
I I don't remember anything I did like I
I saw one and I was like I was like I
did an episode in Maui I was like what
the [__] did I do in Maui and I was like
oh that's right Mama's Fish House Ranch
we went surfing with this guy named
turtle or not Turtle I forget his name
but I was like yeah Turtles from the
movie the North Shore but he did have a
name like that I forget his name there's
a metaphor that's coming out when I'm
hearing all this stuff because you've
had such extraordinary experiences but
they were so crammed together that you
weren't able to appreciate them and that
ties into what you were talking about
the financial burdens on families that
people can't enjoy the little moments oh
if I had if I had given one of these I
mean I did give them one to every
different person but if I could gift one
of my experiences to one person and
allow them five days six days to do it
they would talk for the rest their about
that for the rest of their life but so
much of [__] just like there's a there's
a lesson here there is I wish I'm glad
we have to appreciate yeah it's so so
good dude and I haven't even gotten to
all the good times like I I'm f i
remember reading about you in Rolling
Stone are you serious I swear to go cuz
my younger brother had gotten a rolling
stone uh subscription I it was like one
of those scams or was whatever but we
were so excited to get a magazine cuz
before the internet you're like and it
would come in the mailbox and I remember
going this guy is me me and this guy
would be such good friends and it's so
so weird yeah to be here what is that
what was that 20 years ago that was
written I was it was
1997 20 years ago 20 years ago I I did
my hour special I did my hour special on
April 1st 2016 19 years to the day that
that article came out that's ain't that
crazy
awesome yeah cuz I yeah and that [__]
that blew me away I was like that's to
the day I was like oh this is dud I
totally believe in God I don't believe
in accidents yeah I yeah Special was
released November 11th 11-11 that's my
lucky number wow dude all these things
just lined up where you're like oh it
couldn't have happened differently I'm
so happy yeah praise the Lord for that
that's awesome yeah I'm a hardcore I
talk about God on stage a little bit
sometimes do and people and you can see
people tuning out I'm like listen man
what the [__] wrong with you like so
what if you don't believe I can't just
say like I listen to people talk about
eating mushrooms and I enjoy it I don't
like eating mushrooms kind of freaks me
out now like but I can still enjoy the
experience I understand that you saw
something [__] magical yes you know I
don't know yeah I agree with all that
how much how are we doing on time uh I
looked at the wrong thing oh my gosh
we're already at an hour and 20 minutes
okay we're flying yeah this is [__] dude
I love hanging out with you this is
awesome we should do a podcast uh we
should do a podcast
where what we should do is a podcast
where it's like round robin
stories oh that's awesome so like get
four comics in you can only interrupt to
punch up the stories but so like it's a
great live show where we
go yeah like right where we go all right
so that is a really great live show do
that up in the belly room four Comics
all sitting on stage we go okay so we're
going to start it off with uh uh best
fight story yep and then everyone tells
their best fight story and we all plch
it up and it just keeps going you know
how like I guess the term is a Charlie
topper someone who like tries to tell a
better story than what you got oh that's
cool it makes me think like did a little
improv at one point and like people
would start like singing a song and then
you would go oh and that makes you say
this it makes you say so it's like
you're telling your fight story then I'm
like oh you have to start going oh
what's my fight story oh oh oh all right
and then be great the story the show I
really wanted to do was I wanted to do
um uh I want I tried to I kind of I say
I tried to sell this I soft pissed at
The Comedy Central but I think it's
something we could do at all things
comedy now is I wanted to
do um almost like this is your life
about Comics so like go bring in bring
in uh 10 of the best comics in the
country you're 10 of the best
storytelling Comics 10 of the best
Comics yeah you it doesn't need to be
storytelling but it's just 10 great
comics and then go um all right today
we're talking about David tell Doug Stan
hope Ry Lang uh uh Nick doollo and Jim
Gaffin yeah and so everyone tells their
best stories about those and then take
all those 10 comics and then put them
into episodes this is the day tell
retrospective epis and so you're hearing
everyone's story about you know what's
so funny I wanted to I battle around
with the concept but they told me it was
too
dark it was the opposite of a roast cuz
like I just don't I can't I don't have
time for the negativity I I I can't I
can't allow myself into that I it hurts
too bad I'm too sensitive I'm way too I
totally I don't know what happened to me
I somewhere along the line I started to
feel like I got a second chance at life
I don't know how or what but just cuz I
grew up in a very NE Philly NE whatever
I I feel like Ebenezer Scrooge every day
where i'm like this is all so beautiful
I'm not worthy of any of this love from
God or the universal however you want to
put it and I'm like how can I share this
Joy with people and then I was like why
does it sucks that we wait until
somebody dies that we tell them how we
really feel like why they don't even get
to hear what you really think and I was
like what and I know this is so dark but
was like What if everybody got to tell
stories about you that they always
wanted to like moments that we all
affect each other's lives in such a
positive way but for whatever reason we
don't share that we can't be like dude
there was a night I wanted to [__]
kill myself and I saw you at the comedy
store and you talked and you asked me
how it was going we went and got pizza
and I realized everything was going to
be okay put all those stories together
it' be incredible there a lot of guys
where I I would just I could totally
celebrate yeah and go like oh yeah let's
celebrate everybody that's an
interesting it's the opposite of a roast
and you know what I said an hour ago I
was like dude I got to stop giving away
my ideas on the
[Music]
podcast now we're
just exactly we're just coming there's
Network assistants like oh yeah oh what
if we pitched a show that was the
opposite of a roast oh there's so many
shows I want to do there's so many shows
I want to do there's so much I want to
do I feel like what I would like to do
is I'd like to micromanage my day in a
4-Hour burst so just work for 4 hours
that's all you can do by the way I don't
myself up anymore and just go within the
4 hours I'm going to do this project
this project this project and this
project and and and then that'll be my
every day I'll just plug in four hours a
day and work on four projects and get
four projects on running then I get
distracted and I'm like I gotta book a
podcaster who did we just say I wanted
to get oh I want to get Charlie Murphy I
wonder if I could get him on my podcast
that'd be awesome
yeah who was the other person I just
said the other day I was like we just
talked about I was like I want to get
that guy on my podcast I just remember
Charlie
Murphy man I'm getting old we go back I
feel like my brain starts up and then it
stops goes I got an idea hold on I'll be
right back and I'm like wait where you
going huh buddy yeah I've got I I need
to I need to call I need to call the
belly room and see if I can do a night
of just stories and see if I
can I bet I I bet I could figure it out
I don't need I don't need a thousand
people I just need like what does belly
room said 100 not even I could do that I
don't know if I don't know if anyone
show up 100% they
would that' be so
cool
um yeah I haven't done a set at the
store in a little bit cuz I've been like
on the road so much I feel really guilty
when I don't I'm I'm not at the store a
lot but I feel even more guilty when I
don't see my kids I think and the cool
thing is that Adam's cool with that he's
like no I get it he's like I'm already
got a [__] ton of comics that are
trying to get spots when you don't want
a spot that helps me out yeah and I'm
like good but don't forget I'm a comic
you know like like that's all my only
thing is like it's so much fun when I'm
there but I end up I always end up
partying I always end up going to the
back bar and getting a cocktail Ron
White will walk through and everyone's
like Hey Ron White's drinking come on
let's go back there and you're like okay
yeah hey St Hope's in town hey Marilyn
Manson's here and you're like shut the
[__] up yeah it's the craziest but I
don't know so let's tell the machine
story and then I'll tell the machine
story but just interrupt me okay cuz
I've seen the shirts yeah and reny and
Ari have told me and they were like dude
this is the craziest thing ever it's the
it's the greatest story and I and by the
way I'm going to time it cuz I'd like to
try to see if I can tell you the whole
story with what I find interesting in it
in like under seven minutes okay um and
normally the story takes 13 minutes oh
wow dude you want to talk about it like
someone said to me you know I'm a
Storyteller so uh I'm making fun of you
and I I know you're a friend of mine but
I don't remember who you are who said
this but we were working together
somewhere uh I know who it is it's a I
want to say it's Rocky Dale Davis who I
love introducing bedtime go to bed and
wake up at the same time every day to
keep healthy sleep what that's
interesting get started what time why am
I doing this now can I do this
later
cancel that's really cool all right we
set a
stopwatch so yeah uh when I was 22 I got
involved with the Russian mafia
how I'm very simply I started taking
Russian
classes where in Florida State okay this
was it up year yeah and I was not a good
I was not a good student I literally I
all they needed 14 kids in the class so
the lady that was teaching in the class
was just
like if you take Russian I'll give you a
c that's how you got into it yep and so
I took Russian 1 2 3 and four never
learned a word and Russian 4 they're
like we're taking a study abroad trip if
you go you get a minor I was like done
son so I went to Russia in 1995 amazing
and this 1995 is when the Russian mob
ran everything and they they told us
that our very first night I'm in the
back of the room like this trip just got
awesome they're like we've paid off
these two young gangsters the word for
that in Russian is banditi they these
band are going to live with you they're
going to walk you to class walk you back
from class take you on field trips don't
speak to them there in the mafia I'm
like uh they're going to be my best
friends so that that's what I did first
night grabbed a Bala vodka knocked on
the door had a sentence all planned out
I studied it all day but the second I'm
face to face with a real Russian
gangster it floods out of my head and
all I say to him in Russian in his
doorway was I am the
machine and that's what he starts doing
he goes what I'm like I'm the machine
brings me in a room full of nine rushing
gangsters all drinking and just goes
everyone stop tell them what you said
I'm like I'm the
machine and they loved me they loved me
and we partied all summer all summer the
guy that answer the door eager was like
my best friend we stole a boat ran a
pool hall scam and then one day we take
an overnight trip to Moscow and eigor
tells me he goes I can't go I said why
not he goes different Mafia runs train
different Mafia runs moscal he's like
don't worry I just a b they'll take care
of you so he introduces me to my two new
gangsters for the train eigor and Igor
and he says to him he goes guys this is
the machine if you give the machine
vodka you'll have a great time wow and
the bigger two eagor is ready for me
he's excited he's like I can't wait to
play with a machine like I'm like he's
like the machine sits in first class I'm
like this is what I'm talking about
booze food and as we take off everyone
that works on the train comes in to pay
their respects the conductor rips off
the Stars and Stripes to his shirt gives
them to me and goes this is a present
for the machine I'm 22 years old going
oh these machine stories might have
gotten out of control
oh my gosh we go to the bar card get
more vodka and Igor says to me in
Russian he goes machine go behind the
bar and grab bread in Russian and I
understood him finally I'm like I'm
learning the language I'm learning the
language through not through flashcards
and textbooks but by joining the mafia
behind the bar like eagor I know what
you said he's like go for you machine
can you find cheese and I was like SE
he's like can you find vodka I was like
I already know that one give me another
one he's like grab the money I'm like
huh he goes grab the money and I realize
we're robbing the bar cart and I'm the
one doing it hooked on phonic Style
grab the money walk out to my classmates
see me and they're like you're in so
much trouble within five minutes head
chaperon comes to our first class cabin
door opens it with that liberal arts
confidence is like like this is over
you're done like lighting me up you're
done eigor looks at me confused yeah
takes a big sip of vodka spits it in her
eyes and goes no one talks to the
machine like that
oh my
gosh shuts the door in her face and he's
like screw that beach this is Rasha
don't worry Suka when we get done when
we goes goes when it gets dark we have
good time I'm like what are we doing
when it gets dark reaches in his pocket
pulls out a ring of keys and he's like
we're rubbing the whole train holy [__]
so you think I think I'm a good person I
think my first response to that
statement would be not me I'm going to
go back and work on my verbs apparently
that's not who I am and so when he said
that I just was like all right let's
start with my class so we robbed them
first then robbed the whole train and
then came back what do you mean you
robbed them did you put masks on and
have guns no we wait till they fell
asleep went in uh and as they were
sleeping one someone would open the door
someone would crawl in pull the bags out
I'd go through the bags we'd Slide the
bags back in shut the door next train
next thing next thing nobody woke up
nobody caught if they woke up Eagle
would spit vodka in their
eyes oh my gosh Rob the whole train go
back drink all night
rushan style until 6:00 a.m. train pulls
into Moscow Suns up door opens same
teacher not mad smiling which is odd
looks at me and goes I want to be the
one to tell you they've alerted the
police and I look out and I see the
whole class in their pajamas talking to
two police officers they're upset
they've been robbed I get it eigor says
don't worry I speak to police for both
of us goes out to the cop who's taking a
statement grabs him by the arm and
starts shouting him in russan suck oh
like just pointing into his mouth
pointing like literally yelling at this
guy and I'm sitting in the back going
this isn't how I would have approached
this situation now the cop's just
staring at me and I hear him bark out P
good which I don't even know what that
means but it doesn't sound like you're
okay stay there yeah walk out to the cop
who's standing in front of the class I
just robbed next to the gangster I
robbed them with and my only thought at
that time was this isn't how I plan on
spending my second junior
year I get my second junior year I get
five steps from the cop who looks
impatient he takes two big steps grabs
me by the arm spins me away from my
class away from eigor pulls me right to
his face and he goes so I understand
you're the
machine I'm like he's like tonight you
party with us I go wait I'm not in
trouble and he gets so close to me I can
smell his morning cigarette and he goes
no screw that [__] this is Rasha oh my
five six minutes that was six minutes
God that's the best thing I've ever
heard that was six minutes I'm that is
if I could tell it and I could probably
shorten that what are you getting it
ready for Conan oh that's awesome I just
want to have it like if he wants me to
tell the whole story I want to tell it
in under 7 minutes but I want to be able
to tell it and then him be able to
switch subjects and me not have to tell
the whole story dude that's incredible
it's a it's the best story that's ever
happened so you what the crazy thing is
it went viral on Facebook the reason it
went viral I think is that the first few
people to com comment on it were
obviously friends of mine because it's
Facebook and it was kids from the class
that knew and and they were like like
yes Bert totally robbed us by the way
here's pictures of everybody and they
posted pictures in all the comment
section so then the first authentic say
million people that saw this were like
holy crap this is a true story and they
shared it and then and then all those
people were like holy crap this is a
true and then people who heard it was
like that was true I didn't care that it
was true they were like it's a good
story it's true so that's why it went
viral do you have any more machine
t-shirts yeah can I buy one I'll just
give you one yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah of
course yeah I'm trying to make a Mickey
manle Jean t-shirt but I can't I'm
having a hard time doing
it that's my new I I it's just something
I've always said as I got the Mickey
manal jeene but Rogan and sigura just
mocked it the whole time oh that's
hilarious yeah I want to tell Dude I
have a buddy of mine that worked like in
Sports Marketing he was like one of the
Pioneers in it yeah so he was a huge
Mickey Mano fan yeah so he said like
when uh pagers were becoming popular
yeah he got Mickey mano a deal where he
got like a do he
to be the celebrity endorser for this
line of pagers and was right when they
blew up and he got like Mickey Mano like
two bucks a month for everyone that got
sold or something like that it made
Mickey mano a ton of money so they
became like best friends and drinking
buddies oh my God and he said he was in
Mickey manel's bar once and and he was
like Mickey Manel could be a real
[__] and uh the father came over with
a kid Mickey had been drinking and he
was like and Mickey man was a dick and
the guy leaves like a heartbroken this
kid my buddy looks at him he's like you
know what Mick you're a real [__]
[__] and he was like what did you say
and he called him out so then the guy go
Mickey Manel realizes he's being a dick
comes back that my friend goes gets the
guy and his kid yeah signs autographs
for him takes a picture and then he and
then Mickey Manel signed him an
autograph that said to John you you
underlined are the real [__] [__]
Mickey Manel and I'm like how awesome is
to have an F-bomb autograph from Mickey
Manel [__] yes I found like I always was
drawn to like guys like Mickey Manel
John Daly like guys that uh like would
go out and party and then perform the
next day yeah cuz I always felt like
that was
like there are people who are like no no
no game tomorrow I got to get to bed by
7 yes I wish I was that guy but what
would happen to me is I'd stay up all
night worrying about the game I was
going to I I knew it right away I was
going to say would you get nervous would
you get in your head like I like and
what's interesting is like before my
specials
um I I never drink before you know like
when I'm leading up to a special I don't
drink so I like to be sharp and I like
to be and I think that does apply to
standup because you don't want to be
hung over and be like [__] I started
sweating in the middle of it years ago I
learned my lesson I don't drink on stage
I stopped drinking like it was terrible
got out of control always bring 21 shots
or something cuz people just kept on
sending them up to me to see if they can
and I didn't realize it started to
become sport for them oh yeah and they'
be like 19 and I'm like I just tell the
bar don't send them up I go don't send
up shots and I go don't let anyone walk
a shot up the stage I don't trust that
[__] and no and that's what somebody
else told me they were like dude
somebody could have put drugs in there
they could have put poison in there I
was like oh God Gary Valentine got
roofied one time how do you know if
you've been ruied uh you know I've been
ruied you know how do you know good
night you're like wow that's crazy I
woke up and I was in a font front lawn
how did I get there oh you don't
remember anything yeah you don't
remember anything like any you don't
remember anything God that's frightening
yeah I think I might have been roofied
in Tampa either that or I roofied self
yeah so what's even funnier is I was in
Scottdale one not Scottdale Phoenix one
time and this guy walked up with a shot
and he just looks sketchy yeah and I was
like and he was like hey let's do a shot
and I was like H I don't really take
shots from just do a [__] shot man I
bought you a shot just take the shot
come on and I go how do I know there's
not something in that and he goes well
you think I rofy you I was like I don't
know and he goes hey man no offense say
I do rofy you what am I supposed to do
with this body and I was like oh that's
right I'm a big guy to get out of a bar
like what do you have a wheelbarrow like
how are you going to get me out of the
[__] bar and I was like oh yeah I
guess I'm safe like cuz if I do pass out
I just go here I land here Andre the
Giant style 500 who's going to rofy
Andre the Giant he was ruy L you know
that story where he drank like something
like 500 beers and they just put a sheet
over him cuz they couldn't move him from
the bar are you serious yeah Rody Piper
God rest is all at the best drinking
stories ever I would I really wish you
anyone says serious if anyone says
serious my phone automatically goes huh
did you need
me um so what got you into booing do you
remember the first beer you ever had
like yeah I remember the first beer it
was with Alan rager and Cayman lazara
and we were in freshman in high school
and we went out behind Adam's house and
we each had like maybe I had a beer
maybe we had three beers tops yes I was
definitely buzzed and Mrs rer uh we
walked out in front of the house and we
were with these girls Allison Williams
Jenny Powers Corey rabaya Natalie Annis
and we were all like
we're all wasted we're so hammered yeah
and everyone thought we were cool yes
and then Mrs rer called she's like boys
come inside I need to talk to you so we
go inside and she is
like and she's sits at their kitchen
table and she dumps out all the beers on
the table the empty beer cans she had
gone and collected them and she's like
who are these and we're
like uh we were like what was his name
Chris uh we said it we blamed it on uh
Chris oh what was his
name I wish I could remember his name he
was a he had red hair we blamed on him
and Ryan Quinn and we were like they're
theirs and they're like seriously and
we're like no they're theirs we weren't
drinking the overwhelming feeling I had
in that moment I wish there was a word
for this I wish there was a word for the
thing where [__] goes down but your
brain thinks of the weird thing it
doesn't think of the thing it should be
thinking of yes it goes like like in
that moment I remember going I'm G I'm
I'm G to get in trouble for uh drinking
my my parents are going to find out um
I'm in ninth grade this could be a big
problem but that wasn't my overwhelming
thought my overwhelming thought was I'm
amazed at how how this fluid could make
me care less about this situation I was
like that is impressive I was like
that's a very self-aware thought to have
as a 14-year-old kid like hey I know
this should be concerning me but somehow
this lick quid changed my perspective on
things I was like I am ex I am oddly
cool In This Moment like she asked me if
we were lying and I was like No And I
was like that was sellable I was like it
had I not been drinking she would know
I'd been drinking and I was just so the
sickness is the cure and I was like wow
I remember being like this feels it was
a little tingly and I go it just feels
like it feels right and I wasn't a big
drinker ever until like I went to Russia
and then when I went to Russia I
remember having an oddly surreal feeling
that first or second night I parted with
the mafia where I was like where I was
like hey
man beer makes every everyone a little
cooler to be around there's no like real
pressure like when you hung out with the
mob and you were sober they were oddly
distant and not really uh
uh conable is that the word like they
were like it was really tough sometimes
to like not with eigor but with the rest
of his friends like if you walked in
they were like who the [__] is this guy
but if you drank with them they were
like ah this guy's great and I was
making everyone laugh and I was like I
was like you know what I can't believe I
didn't do this more in college I can't
believe I sat with people sober more and
so when I came back from Florida State
my girlfriend at the time had slept with
my best friend wow and so the within 5
days of being home I found that out and
found out I got the clap from them and I
was like I was like [__] man so like
this great story I had on I only told it
to like a handful of people cuz for the
most part my reality was I am humiliated
I'm a cockled and and I've got a vural
disease and I've only had sex with two
people in my life at the time yeah and I
was like I was like [__] floored and
my buddy Mike Osborne said to me that
first night where I
realized uh this is a little bit of a
GameChanger like this is a game changer
in in my in my in who I will be for the
rest to my life I will never be cool
calm Bert everything's perfect no
worries in this world I got it going on
you know uh part I wasn't I wouldn't say
I was technically a party animal at the
time but I definitely threw all the
parties yes I didn't drink a lot at the
time up until that point you already
cool like you were accepted and fun and
yeah I was the funniest guy in my
fraternity I organized all the socials I
would been social chairman for like 3
years running and uh and no one was
going to stop me from being social CH
cuz I threw the greatest parties I mean
just epic um where' that come
from like do you have crazy uncles is
had crazy UNC my mom we never really
partied much as a kid but I remember I
remember I have I have big Ideas like
I've always had really big ideas and a
lot of a lot of which in Hollywood get
shot down like where you like I had a
show called uh black versus white where
I wanted me and a black guy to compete
to find out who the superior race was
every week and I was like and everyone
in Hollywood no one would buy it they
were like nah and I was like but you
understand that if you did have the
balls to buy it and you did air it yeah
there would be protests but more than
anything everyone would tune in and go
come on white people you know come on
black people and then someone would go
where the [__] are Mexicans at you know
but you and it would be a [__]
light-hearted fun show between friends
so there would be no hatred it would be
[__] bringing people together and no
one when you could see the similarity
like there are no strangers like once
you get to really know people there's
it's like oh my God we're all yeah and
so and so but in college our remember um
going to thr the first party and I was
like I remember being
like we should fill the lounge with
water and everyone's like what I go I
bet we could do it like up to the
windows so what we'll do is we'll put
visqueen we'll Vis Queen it off and
we'll make it waterproof what's this
queen Vis Queen was like Vis Queen was
the party starter in college okay so we
Vis queened off the lounge it's like uh
it's this this it's thi thick plastic
okay really thick plastic it comes in
like 50 by 50 sheets fold it up and it
was it be black you get it blue you get
it clear so we got blue visqueen or I
want maybe black visqueen and we went
through we put it out in the yard very
meticulously and made it as big as the
measurements in the lounge and then we
taped it off very aggressively and we
double layered it then we folded it up
so that it was in this little square
brought into the center of the lounge
cleared out the lounge and then just
unfolded it and it just went up the
walls and then we taped it to the walls
and so now it's taped I mean people were
coming in going you're a [__] idiot
but that was the difference you're a
[__] idiot and then but no one was
saying no that's awesome and so we
filled up the lounge with water and it
was the greatest party you've ever been
to in your life like [__] everyone's
just in this one room filled with water
just having a [__] blast and then
like and then You' and then I'd go we
should do a party where I go one party
was like I just came in I went the
chapter and I was like I want to do a
party called unga bonga and they're like
what is it from catty Shack thank you
thank you so I had had a dream and I and
I just said to them guys I had a dream
like if I if I could have ever been one
thing better than a comic it would have
been like a like a inspirational speaker
or like you know like like I go I had a
dream I said we were all stranded on an
island with with tri Els and the whole
point of this and I just told them this
story and the whole [__] fraternity
was into it and they're like [__] it
let's do it I go we're doing it 30
Thursday we need a king and we need to
carry him through campus in the middle
of the afternoon all in Grass skirts no
underwear grass skirts on a throne and
so we just did it and it was like and we
got this guy Chilly Willy to be king
unga bonga and and we just it was like
[__] 180 dudes all in Grass skirts
wore paint just chanting through the
school and everyone was staring at us it
was a cool feeling and then we got to
the Triad El house they didn't know we
were having a social that night they had
no clue oh that's just walked over and
we knocked on their door and it happened
to be dinner time like 5:00 dude that's
an amazing like there's nothing better
than like I love donuts yeah but they're
the best feeling in life is when you
walk into a kitchen there's surprise
Donuts you're like can anybody have one
of these that's my problem with drinking
right you know what I mean but you did
that with a party you just brought the
party to their house we just showed up
to their house and we said tonight and
so then I said I said to Willie who who
by the way was really funny and kind of
missed his career as a comic I said you
just say [__] in a language anguage and
I'll translate so to give me time to
think of what what I needed to say and
he was like mitubishi Subaru uh camon
Canon camera every REM do you ever see
that happy days where uh Ralph malf and
poy and Richie like go to a cabin and
there's chicks and uh I think it was
Ralph malth and poy pretended to be from
another country and Rie translated for
them so they could get chicks and I just
remember Ralph going mock mock like when
he likes something
Bo it was like that and it and and these
girls all the girls came out and I we
were we all knew them very well I want
to say I was I might have been hooking
up with this one girl I think it was
right before I cheated on my girlfriend
before I went to Russia and this girl
became like the love of my life like to
this day one of my best friends in the
world we end up living together in New
York like not not sexually but like
living together in New York she's one of
the greatest human beings I've ever I
love her with I will always love her and
but she was out there and like all these
girls just came out and they were coming
out the open the windows and looking out
and it was like it was really like it
was crazy and we're like the party is
tonight and at midnight uh we're going
to get we're going to do a ceremony or
something and so these girls are [__]
Tuesday night or Thursday night and
these girls were like all [__] came
out and they were all barely naked with
just grass skirts and war paint and we
filled the whole house with sand we made
a slide going from the second floor down
around the corner into the first floor I
mean it was just like it was this I mean
[__] insane we built a big pool in uh
in our in our cafeteria like our dining
hall we built a big pool and it became
like the most epic party we had ever had
and so and then the next year they're
like I mean everyone's like we got to
take it big and so like the final year
we had it uh the final year I was there
we had it and I think I'd probably
distan myself from so social chair at
the time I was there seven years so you
know and so but I told them I was like
they're like seven years of college down
the drain I go how do we get this there
I remember the social chair at the time
like how do we take this big and I was
like let me be in charge of like just
making sure it's epic you set up
everything in here and I'll make sure
it's epic so I got us this is [__]
horrible I got us like a [__] like
10- foot python I got I just uh one of
our fratority brothers had one I said
I'd like to put him up on a tree we had
a tree in the middle of the dining hall
I said I just like to have him hanging
from the tree and he's like yeah you
won't [__] move so we wrapped him up
in the tree and he just stayed there uh
I got chickens I got goats I got animals
to be all over the place how just bought
them just [__] you could just go out
to a farm go I'll take you know chickens
are like super [__] cheap so like how
much is a chicken uh well I I want to
say we got these for like a dollar a
piece they sent them to you in like a
little [__] you can order them online
and they'll send them to you in like
boxes little tiny boxes you get a chick
it'll be there in a day you can you can
you can send someone chickens tomorrow
and then be like what the [__] do I do
with this that's awesome I'm guessing on
prices but I remember you know top top
top billing ever like animals were like
our thing at the there was a period
where we're like we're going to go we're
going to [__] cook a pig tonight and
you just go out and buy a pig it was
nothing and they cut it up for you and
they bring it in bury it in a hole I
think we buil we burned we cooked a pig
you just buried it in the ground so
that's in the backyard it was really
[__] insane except like a [__]
misstep I think I allotted some of the
money for cocaine and ecstasy and just
started handing it out like people were
coming in I was like we used to call
them beans back then I was like you up
for a party Bean you up for a bean
Groove mix is what we call cocaine
Groove mix and they were like yeah and
so everyone got way too [__] high and
then people started killing the animals
and I think we got in a lot of trouble
Jesus was a [__] horrible idea I
remember you know it a lot of redneck
got really bad got really bad it was
like rednecks are like rednecks like my
wife's a redneck she loves animals but
she doesn't have a problem killing an
animal like it's not it's in her sweet
spot yes like she like they they we
killed a chicken uh when we were out at
their house in Georgia and it's just you
just grab by the neck and spin it around
it breaks its neck and I remember seeing
one guy was like I'm [__] hungry he
just grabbed the chicken broke it up
feathered it put it in the deep fryer
made Fried Chicken everyone's eating
fried chicken like someone go grab
another chicken and I was like oh God
and then in my head I was like I was
like hey wait don't let's not kill the
animals and then the guy's like why what
are we going to do give them back we're
going to have [__] 20 chickens
running around the house like let's cook
him up and I was like oh God I was like
I'm going home I'm going to be wallowing
in this [__] mistake but like uh like
yeah we've done that I I just trying to
have fun I we did that anytime you
involve an animal you really forget the
responsibility you have as an adult like
cuz you you think it'll be fun like we
did a pilot me Brett Ern and Theo Von
did a pilot for TBS where we it was we
started a eternity so we which by the
way totally backfired totally backfired
how did that not work well we we put out
an ad in
uh
Craigslist hey are you lost are you a
man are you lost do you feel like you
you don't know what the [__] you're
going to do in life do you feel like you
feel like you're not having fun anymore
do you want to just live relive The
Glory Days join our fraternity meet us
at burnam bonam Murray at [__] what
so it's like old school the reality show
Yes except you got to remember the
people that would reply to that are
probably genuinely [__]
lost I was going to say the it should
have been like let's have some laughs
who likes beer and boobs and fun it one
dude was gotten out of Iraq or
Afghanistan he had hardcore
PTSD um another guy one guy's dead now
oh God another guy was just recently
engaged and like the first night like
like idiots it's me Brett and Theo
organizing this so we're like we going
to have a party we're not going to like
girls we're we're ordering [__] and
porn stars so we got a bunch of
prostitutes and porn stars this guy
comes up to me he's like I think I
cheated on my wife I'm like oh God I was
like did they get all that stuff on
camera no he's like BD I think I know
you're supposed to be one of my leaders
man I think I cheated on my wife and I
was like oh don't worry about it it's
not a big deal everyone cheats I guess
God [__] happens it's a T show don't
worry about it it's not real it's not
real and he was like really I go yeah
you were doing it as a character right
and he was like there was no camera we
were just in the bathroom and I was like
yeah but you knew that you had a mic on
he goes I had a mic on I'm like oh never
mind never mind it was [__] I mean
there was a point where like cameramen
would just holding the cameras going I
can't [__] film this like I got we it
was it was a beautiful [__] house but
one of the points is we had organized to
steal a goat for our our our mascot for
our for our uh fraternity yeah so they
like and production was a little I would
say lackluster and I I say that
respectfully it was just very
complicated to try to produce this so
we're in this party bus and we're like
all right we we need a mascot and I knew
there was an address that we could go to
that we had purchased a goat so we could
go and the farmer knew we were just
going to go grab a goat yeah and and but
they no one in the van knew and so we go
up
and I was like here pull over here pull
over here so and I have I think I have a
walkie so I pull over here so I go all
right guys we're going down and so I was
like all right and so I was just going
to go down the street but [__] Ernst
is like come on taking go like I don't
even think Ernst knew we were we we were
green lit to steal the goat cuz I wanted
to keep it real and he's like going to
take the back route approach from the
south he like he's like Billy Martin in
that classic Mickey Manel story shooting
the horse he and he goes come on and
then they just disappear I go where the
[__] did they go and then they're
disappearing and then one of The
Producers comes up and like this is the
wrong address and I was like what he's
like you're supposed to go a mile down
it's on the right so get everyone back
in the car and I go okay I was like guys
and all of a sudden Brett and [__]
this other guy kill you and come out
with a [__] goat and I was like oh
[__] we really stole a goat I was like
in the car go go I like abort abort
we're just we just got to Goat let's go
someone go back and pay that Farmer for
his goat and so we really stole a
[__] goat and then I mean this whole
thing was this like they set up a
powderpuff game of us to play female uh
football
players but like like it was just it was
just and I I don't mean this out of
disrespect with B bonam Murray but like
it was just not totally properly
produced yes so like none of us all of
us are showing up in jeans and t-shirts
and it's raining and it's cold and we're
drunk well that was the other thing is
they couldn't control our drinking so we
were drunk 100% of the day like when we
woke up we started drinking when we we
drank the whole [__] time yeah so we
go to do the Powderpuff game and all the
girls are in pads and like and we're
like like hey man this is going to hurt
and they're like oh you know like the
producers like that's the point like we
want to make it fair and so we play like
the first round and the girls are like
[__] hitting us hard as [__] and and
they score and Brett erns is like [__]
this he's like team meeting and all the
girls are lined up for the [__]
kickoff right they're going to kick off
to us and he's like and BR gives the
most moving speech
[__] these [__] we're going to
[__] light these [__] up do you
understand me I want to see these girls
bleeding on the [__] floor no ho bar
they're taking hits at us you want
equality I'm showing these [__]
equality the ball goes to him we give it
to the biggest guy yes the ball goes to
him everyone protect him I know football
I want a wedge okay I will lead the
wedge and when you go at these [__]
take their [__] knees out I want them
[__] dude we could have been arrested
for spousal abuse I oh my gosh we beat
the [__] out of these women to the point
where like we just came through and
we're clotheslining [__] and they're
just like and then the girls are like
what are you guys doing this is just for
TV and we're like no you were hitting us
hard now we're hitting you hard this is
a real [__] game this it would be the
best and they're and they're going we
can't use any of this we can't use any
of this you guys are beating up women
and we're like we're playing football
they want to play football they have
pads we don't have [__] pads this is
how you play [__] football and I mean
it was [__] epic and they're like
great won't be able to use any of
that that's incredible dude it was the
greatest show I've ever shot that no one
will ever see it was so [__] funny we
got a we got a band so we got all these
prostitutes all these porn stars and we
get a band and uh and and the band I
mean I don't I did not organize the band
but the band was [__] amazing they
show up all they've got they're three
girls all they can do is sing they don't
really even play instrument
they got a whole mailand behind them and
in their rider was we need 10 bottles of
Jack Daniels and we need uh 20 pillows
and so what's the name of this band I
don't know I wish I could remember the
name they were [__] amazing they show
up they have black tape like eye eye
black under their eyes on their nipples
is a black X they're in the most amazing
shape you've ever seen and on their
vaginas is just a piece of black tape
covering they're totally shaved just
covering what would be the working part
of their vagina just a piece of black
tape and they're naked and they have and
like knee high leather boots on and
their hairs are in like little [__]
crazy bun ponytails and they're like are
you [__] ready to party we're
like this is going on TBS like can we
clean up the language and they like [__]
you you want a [__] party let's
[__] party and they're like where the
[__] bird and I'm I'm in like a onesie
I think at the time and I'm like right
here and they're like get over here
[__] and they each take a sip of
vodka and then grab me and spit it in my
mouth and then pass me down the line
I've now done three large mouthfuls of
of Jack Daniels not vodka Jack Daniels
and I'm like holy [__] and they're like
let's go they jump on my back they start
beating us with pillows all the feathers
go everywhere and I'm just like oh this
is the best party I've ever been to in
my life we have porn stars and hookers
floating around everywhere grabbing
everyone's dicks it is and then
someone's like let's jump off the house
into the pool cuz the house is like
three stories above the pool now we're
all jumping people are naked jumping
into the pool the producers are like we
need to slow this down this is happening
way too fast I was just imagining
there's some poor production assistant
that's going to moved back to Iowa and
it tells these stories for the rest of
us it was so like I mean we had a hockey
rank I don't know what we were doing on
a hockey rank but we had a hockey rank
for the day and so we went out to go on
the hockey rank and you know Brett this
guy love Brett but he's like dude we're
going to reenact Rocky and you're
like how and then someone like falls and
cracks their head on the ice and we're
like oh should we go to take him to the
hospital and they're like he'll be fine
drink it off it was I'm telling you man
it was the craziest [__] two days of
my life it was two [__] days wait
that was just two days all that happened
in two days we left Friday night we
partied Saturday we came home
Sunday oh my gosh it was insane Sunday
was the day we played football with the
porn with the girls um we did one of the
ice skate on sun ice skting rink on
Sunday
we and then Sunday Sunday night Sunday
night we had a uh an initiation and then
everyone got initiated and we took their
badge and we stapled it on their chest
it was dude crazy if I could get if I
could get the unedited version of this
it could be a movie it was
so I remember there's a point where Theo
is with one of the porn stars and he's
like uh he's like Cy right back we're
like okay and the sound guy comes up and
he's
like come here and I go what and he goes
want to hear this I take my headsets off
and I put on my headsets and you just
hear hardcore [__]
just and I was like what he goes I think
Theo's using the
restroom oh like it was just it was just
[__] like he had totally miked and
just [__] the most beautiful woman
I've ever seen in my life and the was
like hey want to go to the bathroom with
me it was [__] insane dude it was
that's crazy it was the craziest D how
did you get this life your life is I do
have some pretty crazy stories when I
think about it I do have some pretty
crazy stories I mean the story you told
on Ari show is one of the funny hardest
I've ever laughed in my life fly dildos
yeah yeah flying dildos is that's that
was a story I had a hard time telling on
stage because it's true obviously all my
stories are true but that one's so true
and I told it and then the and and the
ending is is what it is the ending is
the dilder get shoved in my mouth and I
think the funniest part about that whole
story was the reveal in the an Frank
house oh yeah oh yeah where I'm like
that to me is the funniest thing ever
yeah that's been that was a great that
was a but like those are all real people
in it so like I couldn't change any of
the facts I felt weird changing the
facts to make it shorter I won't do yeah
like I don't like what people like you
should do it tell it like this I'm like
but that's not how it happens know will
I embellish at times if somebody was
five 11 when i' be like dude this guy
was 634 you know what I mean I don't
mind hiding facts like not telling you
things that happen so that it heightens
the the story I don't mind um I don't
mind I don't mind if someone says a line
differently just to make it a little
better but I can't I can't lie like I
can't be like I have a hard time like
full-blown lying in a story to make it
better I can't do that like I told a
story once about this gang member and I
said oh he was the scariest human being
I've ever met I don't know if that's
true oh but I was definitely
scared he was top five oh yeah you know
what I mean like where you're like oh
Jesus I describ when I first met eigor I
describe him very scary um but he wasn't
actually all that scary and I think
that's sometimes they're the scariest
people yeah well but funny is all the
things I describe about him are things I
learned afterwards about him inter so
like and so I always go God damn it man
I would have never said a [__] word
but like like now you I mean you can see
pictures of eigor online you they're all
over now him and Sasha and do you still
stay in touch with him no and I'm a
little nervous because I like was like
this guy's in the mafia and then I just
everyone post pictures of him and now
I'm like oh I don't know if that was
cool yeah I told the story not knowing
that I you can't be a modern day Mark
Twain and just like yeah like that's
what I would call your T your
storytelling show modern day Mark Twain
modern day Mark Twain hash Mark
Twain how much time have we done I I
don't know I got to go do stuff dude I
could hang out with you all day yeah
this is a great [__] podcast dude so
much fun this is a [__] blast so much
fun I love you bro I appreciate you
letting me do that because that gives me
a lot of confidence going into Conan
know I can tell it when are you going to
do it on Conan Tuesday oh that's awesome
I leave for Boston tomorrow morning um
I'm in Boston for the Wilbur Saturday
night yeah oh you haven't even done the
soldout show yet no oh you're going to
have so much fun I hope and then I love
that
City yeah they were like uh but it's so
I'm I've we'll see I'll be back Sunday I
won't drink Sunday night Monday I won't
drink I'll well if you ever want a sober
ride to The Comedy Store let me know
okay you live around here yeah I live in
Sherman Oaks oh seriously yeah some 5
minutes away this on my way home by the
way I'll hit you up a lot yeah dude I
drive by all the time I'll justt if I
get a spot I'll just give you a text and
say hey what time you going by the store
dude that would be the best awesome do
we did we share numbers or just emails I
think I got your number
I think I have your number I think I
texted you yeah yep got
it
um my daughter saw me my phone the other
day hang on who's
this my daughter saw my phone the other
day and she goes is your phone ever
fully charged and I was like no I'm
always out of battery and she's like you
should change that about yourself and I
was like H it's too hard and she goes no
just get a charger and put it next to
your bed that could really help and I
went I guess you're right she's like no
that's what I did I was like well you're
12 and that's what you
did you said Mom can you buy she didn't
couldn't even do it herself she's like
Mom can you buy me a charger so I can
keep one next to my bed so that I can
charge my phone at night so I always
have a full phone when I go to school
and I went yeah I guess I can do that
she goes no you can totally do that Dad
and I was like oh maybe I'll go on
amazon.com and get a alarm clock that
has a charger so I can plug my I was
like yeah why wouldn't I do that yep
just [__] lazy genius though speaking
of which I'm going to work out I'm going
to run 9 miles today and feel good you
can run 9 miles oh I do it every day
just about I I don't run the whole N9
miles I what I'll do is I'll turn on the
TV and I'll walk like a solid two two
and run you get the warmup going run a
third fourth mile and then take a break
go do some [__] pick up the girls at
school come back get on the treadmill
before dinner do like two more miles
then come back and at the end of the
night everyone's in bed hop on do
another two more miles dude I'm so proud
of you cuz it's all Connected Mind Body
Soul it's all connected you can't get
one stronger without I feel like that is
I feel like that's very [__] accurate
it's 100% true there's Universal truths
and once you make one stronger it's
going to force you to raise your game in
the other things [__] yeah it's awesome
I love you bro thank you so much for
doing this I love you too man thank you
so much
Steve my looked back at all the things
they used to do never had no money and
they always told the truth Daddy didn't
leave no
little so that was Bert ker so thank you
so much Bert for being on the podcast I
love every buy dude you there's the
coolest I had the best day that day cuz
it was the day you and reny were working
together oh okay oh yeah then he went
went to your house then we no this is
what happened he goes are you hungry I
was like yes and I was like let's go to
Domingos cuz I I used all my carbs in
one shot they have a new sandwich there
what do they have it's called the atomic
balsamic okay I like the start of it
okay
this is what it is Carlo just invented
it so you take delicious homemade fresh
from scratch daily chabata bread from
Domingos Good Start good start and then
essentially what it is I don't know all
the
ingredients but it's essentially like a
spicy Italian style ham and cheese
straight up like ham and cheese sandwich
but they use pepper jack they use a
sweet balsamic vinegar
pepper jack a spicy I think there's a
spicy mustard on there with
jalapenos and then like four different
kinds of Italian ham it's one of the
most delicious things I've ever had in
fact when my cheat day starts I think
I'm going to go get like one of those
their Italian beef and a meatball
sandwich if I if I was speaking my my
real truth right now and I was doing
really what I wanted to do yeah I'd be
leaving right now and going and getting
one of those like I don't even want to
finish this like that sounds so it
really is that good like you have to
make a decision when something's that
delicious where you're like am I just
going to crush it as fast as possible or
am I going to try to slow down and enjoy
it and there's no right or wrong answer
to that see that's why I think it's
almost sometimes you have to almost get
like a second one to share that's why
it's good to go with someone so like you
you get a sandwich and but then maybe
Chinese food style the best way yeah you
have this is what you have to do this is
what I think you bring as many buddies
as you can then everybody and you order
a bunch of different sandwiches and you
get them to cut it in thirds so every
you can get a taste of everything right
and because especially when you first
get there you're going to be so hungry
you're going to eat a little bit too
fast yes you're not going to really
remember it or enjoy it cuz it's so and
then and that's why like I usually get
like 3/4 of a way through a sandwich and
then I start realizing oh it's almost
gone it's delicious yeah so that's yeah
go with friends and definitely do it as
a cheat like for f like
be prepared to have more than one
sandwich yeah just it's a beautiful area
of Ino going on a walk yeah there's a
cool Karate Kid mural around the corner
really yeah oh I would have like I would
have done that that's the way to do it
is to really go I would love to do that
is just go in the morning with a
computer and just order like two meals
there like breakfast and lunch that
would be the best or lunch and dinner I
don't know how it works but now I'm just
hungry yeah me too and I'm grateful I'm
so I was grateful let's start the
gratitude list man I was grateful for
that day I got to hang out with Bur prer
then went and had lunch with Steve reny
that is a great day great day I'm very
I'm grateful um for all my friends who
keep helping me like like honestly thank
you people keep recommending me like I
got I got to meet Steve which is coolest
right he's very cool very nice and yeah
I'm just grateful for that I am grateful
uh for my buddy Ryan at Don Carlos
because he bought me a plane ticket to
go see my parents and I had so much fun
I probably wrote another hour is worth
of material just hanging out with my
parents just as last week oh it was so
much fun that's so I got to I texted you
when you were with your dad that was fun
yeah no loose women no heavy drinking or
loose women
now that that that is my favorite just
the idea of saying it to a six-year-old
oh oh dude let's you know what I'm going
to have John from regular hero print up
those t-shirts that just say no heavy
drinking or loose women now oh you
absolutely should I would wear that
every day I got I'm I'm grateful I got
to see it was like uh my I don't even
know how to describe it it's my male
cousin when I was like 12 or 10 who was
like my age now oh he must have been the
coolest person ever him and his brother
were the coolest people ever and him and
his wife were out here and we got to
have breakfast and talk about their kids
his his kids his daughters who are like
my age like they're like 10 and 11 now
oh so now you get to be that cool person
of them I W and I I wish I the the
problem they live in Philly so they no
way
uh I'm not sure where they live a little
bit um he lives in Philly cuz he
actually teaches in DC but then uh he
takes the train every day yeah well uh
two times a week that's genius oh yeah
he he loves it but uh Philly's the best
I want to get a house there right and I
just I apparently he has a really cool
house but I've when I moved out here
they were really young and I have I
can't go back that often so I haven't
got to see them as much so I was feeling
a little bit bad but I got to see them
and then last night I got to show Paula
Animal House which was huge for me
growing up the best that was like my
first uh movie with boobs that was like
my big that was a kid yeah that was the
greatest for and dude John balushi man
you know I'm grateful for John balushi
oh yeah he could do more with a look
like and and K you know what you have to
do if you're an Animal House Fan tell me
you have to see that on the big screen I
don't cuz Belushi's Belushi is even
funnier there's something about a movie
appreciating it the way it's supposed to
be absolutely that ler than life right
amazing he the way he moved his
shoulders he could just have a look in
his eye break the fourth wall amazing
the the uh cafeteria scene maybe my
favorite scene in all of movies ever
just just him going through the the the
line grabbing the food and then see
that's to me okay like right now I'm
working on an idea for me my buddy
Robert the strongman okay
and that Belushi thing if you were to be
a script reader that's not going to pop
off the page if it's like John Belushi
comedically picks out food in the
cafeteria lunch line right yeah you know
what I mean like no matter how much you
describe that it comes to life because
of the actor it comes to life because of
the director that's one of the best
scenes ever and it's not going to
translate on the page it you have to see
it and it it doesn't translate like it
to me I felt bad like Paul was laughing
but I was D I was dying laughing just
being brought back to like the
eight-year-old kid watching it yes and
then and then the see if you can guess
what I am now see if you can guess what
I am now that just so great food Fu that
boy is a pig pig I loved beluchi like
when I went to college I was like that's
who I'm going to be I'm going to be
Bluto blutarski and then that's why it
was so great to have uh Bert ker cuz
Bert is the real life Bluto right yeah
he really did spend like seven eight
years in college and he talks about some
of the parties he threw on this podcast
you have to like it's insane absolutely
insane oh yeah I would I would like the
biggest party animal in the world he hit
an arle Rolling Stone yes I remember
that really I read that that's what I
told him he couldn't believe it and I
remember reading it going you know what
I'm going to be friends with this dude
is I don't know how people can doubt God
like there's just there are no it's
amazing it's just it's all so amazing I
can't believe read that that article
when it first came out yeah CU my
younger
brother um got a Rolling Stone
subscription I I remember it for
sure that and there was something else
good in that uh that uh addition but I
remember that vividly I think he might
have even been on the cover or something
was like country's big you know what I'm
going to Google that uh that I remember
I I remember I
vividly that's unbelievable yeah that
that I'm grateful that just for that
just that you like 20 years what is it
15 20 years that's that's amazing yep I
I I'm grateful for magazine I I had a
ton of magazine subscriptions as a kid I
had game pro I had boy life I had uh
what I think it was those were the main
ones but I also liked uh what was Goofus
and
Gallant uh the it was like people High
Life magazine Highlights yeah highlights
yeah and I'm I was always I loved Goofus
and Gallant but I was I was always
Gallant so it was like my favorite was
just finding the hidden objects oh you
really you like that one yeah where I
was like oh there's a boot in a tree
there's there's the pirate chure chest
bird in the picnic table see I would
always I'd get frustrated if I couldn't
find all eight of them or something so I
that's why I I I went to goof is and
gallon cuz I was like oh I can just
reading I can handle
reading I missed magazines were you know
what was so great and I'm not making
this up what when I went to go visit my
parents my mom got me a wrestling
magazine Just for Old Time sake so great
what was it like was it one of the ones
that you read as a kid well kind of like
when I was a kid wrestling magazines
were the greatest like it was like the
internet that you could touch
like I remember my dad driving us into
this like we would get excited to go
into the city it was like a field trip
without teachers right especially if my
mom didn't come it was always more fun
with just my dad because like we're
going to get a sandwich buddy and
nobody's going to hear about it you know
what I mean
like but then they would have these news
stands in the city and you would see
wrestling magazines that you just didn't
even get in the suburbs like I
consistently would get a magazine called
pro wrestling Illustrated but then
there' be different ones and on the news
stand and you'd have to like make a
decision which had the best posters
which had the better articles um and
then I would even sometimes it would
come down to which there would be that
classified section in the back of a lot
of magazines and I go which one has the
better ads like we uh my younger brother
and I were fascinated with uh the
military as kids so there was a magazine
called Soldier of Fortune and they would
have the best articles and the best like
ads in the back would be like is that we
could buy like a gun or like mercenary
yeah yeah yeah and that's all we would
try to do and it was it was it real was
it like actually oh I definitely believe
so
yeah I want do you think they had like
fake magazines just to get like for boys
like you
can no way like it's kind of like almost
like reality TV like they had like here
this is all the stuff boys would love
you can you could hire a mercenary with
a rifle be let's see if Chris could
stand up to this guy that's a great idea
army green beret Black
Ops was the absolute best I cuz you
actually you had to send in like an
order form I remember I had an envelope
from a magazine like you had to send
like it had to send in to get like it
was CDs for me and I actually put cash
in it hilarious I put cash in I sent it
out wow so much fun and then what we
really wanted to do there was a kid that
was friends with my older brother named
Dave Spore okay and he was the first kid
we ever knew to have a fireworks catalog
what yes and we were like how do you get
a catalog where you can order fireworks
cuz that was Contraband there's still a
legal in Pennsylvania but now there's a
loophole which is glorious there's a
loophole
where you're allowed to sell real
fireworks in Pennsylvania real ones
awesome ones but you just can't you
you're not even allowed to walk in the
store with a Pennsylvania driver's
license you need an out ofate license to
buy
them no way so it's for it's for people
driving down but they don't want yes but
it's a loophole kind of scam because
like fireworks are also illegal in New
Jersey right to the best of my knowledge
but you can have New Jersey driver's
license and show it to the person in
Pennsylvania like yeah it's not
Pennsylvania and state law says you just
need to take them out of the state
within 48
hours so that's what people would do cuz
they're they're illegal in Massachusetts
they're illegal everywhere pretty much
are they really okay yeah you got to go
to cool fun States like Texas or Alabama
I all I remember hearing was West
Virginia that was where everyone I in my
town went my dad would drive us we would
do road trips down to Virginia so we
could get real firecrackers and Skyrock
see they did they did a good job with me
I'm still like I just imagine if I touch
a firework my hand's going to blow off
hilarious yeah I was petrified of that
too yeah and then you know what
honestly uh Jason Pier Paul when he blew
off his fingers ohz I'm like you know
what you got to be careful cuz like last
time Ari was in town me Ari and ren is
easy we lit off fireworks and it is like
the most fun ever but then I was I was
so afraid the cops were going to come
cuz they were so
loud
it was so much louder than I thought
that I just I was like don't run just
start to walk because there was one that
broke I know I told this story but you
know what I'm I'm going to stop myself
I'm grateful for
fireworks I'm I'm grateful for the fact
that you got that you can still play
like kids as an adult be worried that
the cops are going to come because of
firework noise you know I'm my younger
brother I don't know if I should throw
him under the butt well uh a guy I know
was a grownup and him and his friends as
grown-ups like well into their maybe
their third they may have been in their
30s definitely late
20s where uh they had taken advantage of
another loophole where they were selling
fireworks in Maryland good ones it was
like a wholesaler where you walked in
and they had stuff that you'd only seen
in movies like mortar shells that like
giant poom like awesome fireworks and
really loud like skyrockets and
whistlers and all kinds of cool stuff
yeah and these like giant repeater
things where you like light one fuse and
it does like a whole firework like the
thing I lit off in China that sort of
stuff where they were lighting they were
like at a uh I don't know they either
were at a concert or like a bachelor
party where everybody was like in a
hotel and one dude had like a trunk full
of fireworks and they were wasted and
they started to light off fireworks and
the cops came and they all ran and then
they were like hiding in the bushes as
grown-ups and then they were like one of
the guys was like what am I doing I'm 29
years old officer I'm sorry I'm an idiot
and popped out of the bush and it was
like here look if you have to arrest me
I have understand I broke the law if you
want to give me a fine that's great but
I'm not going to
hide see like I almost want to hide like
his fireworks no he's not going to get
in real trouble is he oh I think you can
for sure I think even go to jail oh wait
then never mind sorry kids yeah you
don't want to break the law no I I
thought but okay I used to do this bit
and like a noise complaint I have to
bring this back on stage cuz I used to
do a bit back when I used to do all my
drinking stuff I used to do like an I
used to have an hour's worth of party
material and I I just sort of lost it
somewhere along the way so I never
recorded it put it on TV none of it but
part of it was getting in trouble
sucks but almost getting in trouble's
the most fun thing ever that feeling you
have in your chest where you're like
cops run oh yeah it just for me was like
I never even had the cops for me it was
just like my parent my mom finding out
the one that would' be scary for me like
I never I never maybe that's why I
thought it would be fun for fireworks
because I never had to run and like run
and hide from the cops I never like I
went to S like I went to a couple
parties but never like I think like once
we were like the cops are coming but we
didn't even see the lights yeah yeah
yeah it's just that feel like you just
make it up in your head you're like the
cops are gone no one's called the cops
exactly it's so fun life is so
fun that's I I just like think like cuz
you never really get to think about it
that much you're so focused as an adult
on being an adult and doing adult stuff
you know just to think about it for two
seconds is just fun it is just thinking
about and you know what this is a great
adult gratitude piece of something I'm
grateful for I'm grateful for the police
I'm
grateful that there are brave men and
women who every day put on a uniform
where they know most people are going to
not like them most people have an
aversion to the police they have to they
literally put their life on the line
every they put their life on the line
every day they see the worst of humanity
every
day it's uh not and it it's not only
that they see the worst of humanity I
think it's like the everyday thing just
the fact that you go
back and and and to me forget about like
now the people are some people are mad
at them some people have aversion to
them yeah just the just their job is
scary so tough like so tough like yeah
that's even CU it I don't know when I
was growing up I didn't feel like
everyone had as much of an aversion to
the to the police I know I know people
are scared when they get the cops
driving behind them in the car because
of a ticket or something but I don't
remember being as like it is now but
it's just it's I don't want to be a
police officer it's I don't want I don't
want to have well I wouldn't be able to
put up with it no like everybody's like
oh Steve you're so nice you're the
sweetest person ever uh no I'm a human
being too and if every day people are in
my face yelling at me pulling guns on me
lying to me all the time lying all the
time I would my my I'm not a good enough
person where that wouldn't taint me that
wouldn't change the way I look at the
world and I'm very grateful for how I
look at the world that's the biggest
blessing I have right now is my attitude
and my perception it's very easy I I I
joke a lot that people get their Spirits
broken yes and it's uh I mean you would
have to imagine that the police would
too and they they yes so so so in the
same way but they just they're just
dealing with more so when they when
they're dealing and their Spirits broken
and then then they get frustrated more
easily or whatever the case may be but
it's everyone gets their Spirit broken
in work like it's I think we have to
start acknow like there's something
about social media that's trying to put
like the best version of everything out
there and everybody's like I'm perfect
are you perfect I'm perfect are you
perfect I never get sad do you ever get
sad and it's like we have to start
recognizing that we're human beings life
is not perfect there's going to be stuff
that's almost impossible to deal with
and it is impossible to deal with on
your own so let's start relying on each
other forgiving each other recognizing
the Brokenness in each other and that
we're all going to mess up like I could
know the right thing to do right oh yeah
I could have a game plan to go out and
do the right thing and I'll still mess
up I mess up all the time do you ever do
like you know how you said it's it's fun
almost getting in trouble sometimes
like I'll just get an idea to do
something I know it's the wrong thing to
do but even as a kid I would do it like
i' like you're like I'm not suppos
supposed to push this I'm going to push
it I'm going to push I'm going to push
it it breaks and then you're in trouble
you're like ah like but just like it's
exciting doing something you know that
you're not supposed to do you know what
I do with that the this is the babiest
version of that I use my iPhone and I
see how low the battery will go and I'm
like I am at 1% I at 1% and I'm like and
then I plug it in to make sure it
doesn't
explode well yeah I and I do the same
thing I'm I've never gotten out of
procrastination like if I have to be
somewhere at 1:30 I'm like takes 8
minutes I was speaking of which what
time is it now 2:15 all right I got to
go all right I love you guys thanks for
listening the good times thank you Lee
uh go to awesome steve.com use that
Amazon link I need the money thanks
[Music]
bye all a good
time
[Music]
yesterday was such an easy game for you
to play I then let's face it things are
easier today yes you need some bringing
down get your feet back on the
ground tell
me where all the good G
we all the good time
come where all the good time
come where all the
good where all the
[Music]
good